at the end of time
[Music]
13 o'clock
well hey everybody what's going on it's
Wednesday happy birthday DJ Maniac yeah
uh it's your birthday and you're off to
work yeah that sucks my birthday's next
week actually on uh Tuesday
51 years old
on Tuesday yeah oh and that's another
thing too let me I'll probably like
announce this again at the end if I
remember but next Wednesday's show I
might push it back till Thursday
because my siblings are like taking me
to the Disney parks on Tuesday and
Wednesday like I'm staying with my
sister Tuesday night and then we're
probably gonna be gone all day Wednesday
like I think we're going to Epcot or
something
so I probably will not be back home in
time to do the show on Wednesday night
so we'll probably push it back till
Thursday I said that like on the patreon
poll too but I don't think that that's
posted yet but I'll keep reminding you
guys so you don't forget so don't like
be alarmed like if next Wednesday we're
not on like normal we just push it to
the next day because I don't think I'm
gonna be home but that's all it is so
you know uh so yeah here's everybody uh
Dar uh darlord and darlord Vader okay
okay sorry I can't see um said I finally
caught one live yeah glad glad that you
did we do this uh pretty much every
Wednesday night at about 7 30 Eastern
Standard Time
so um this topic right here
see this is another thing that freaks me
out yeah everybody says like serial
killers and it's like pretty rare and
[__] like that however people are always
suggesting ones to me that I hadn't
heard of before
and this guy I had never heard of before
yeah me neither and you had never heard
of him yeah I see pictures of him and he
does he's not real freaky looking I
don't
know they've heard him looks like Che
Guevara
well he was kind of like Beret engine
well he was rolling to like hippie the
hippie thing this happened like back in
1968 1969 and he was like roll up on the
uh hanging out with the hippies and
stuff like that because he was like
selling drugs and why not
so uh so yeah this [__] and the
thing about it this is another one where
I mystified why he's not better known
um I will say he was only technically
convicted of two murders although they
suspect that he killed at least five
I've seen as many uh as eight but some
of the victims that um they think that
he killed they actually did find them
alive later on because you know people
disappeared and they were transient and
[__] like that back then so but we'll
get into that in a little bit but yeah
so he was only convicted of two but the
thing about it was that the [__] that he
did to the victims was
um pretty [__] up like he went all
dismembering and there was uh probably
some necrophilia involved so you know it
wasn't like
you know he's not remembered because he
didn't do anything particularly horrible
yeah it wasn't LeBron the middle
Strangler right now I will say that like
some of the stuff that um was said about
him in the media at the time like oh my
God like he removed their hearts and
took them away that wasn't entirely true
but it was I mean you know that was
exaggerated but it wasn't that far off
the mark because he did
take organs sometimes just not their
hearts and it wasn't like a big thing
like I think one of the victims had I
think it was maybe her uterus removed
but um yeah so it it was such a big deal
at the time that Kurt Vonnegut
uh you know the the very famous writer
I'm actually a big fan of uh he lived on
Cape Cod at the time and he was like
fascinated by this case and he wrote
about it
um and he called this guy like the
modern day Jack the Ripper because he
did I mean his victims were not sex
workers but um the [__] that he did to
him kind of recalled Jack the Ripper a
bit
um but yeah so one of you guys
recommended this guy I can't remember uh
who it was but I put it in the poll and
it won and I was like fascinated to find
out more about this dude because and
there's even been a couple books written
about him there's one called Helltown
which um which I read it was on the
Kindle unlimited thing for free like you
can read it and then there's another one
called in his garden which I didn't get
to read and then there's one
um that was written by a girl that he
apparently used to babysit when she was
a kid like when he was a teenager in his
20s or something like that and um so she
kind of wrote about her experiences yeah
he babysat kids when he was younger it's
a whole thing but yeah it's like pretty
[__] weird
uh Alice in Wonderland says even being a
bit Jack the Ripper can't be good
exactly exactly that's what I'm saying
like any similarity to Jack the Ripper
yeah it's a huge red flag right there a
huge red flag
um Tammy says she's saying Eddie is our
next Thursday I'm very very jealous so
have fun and tell me all about it
because I've never got to see him
um yeah Leslie Russell said I didn't
know that the this vampire I know the
Sacramento one yeah I kind of feel like
Richard Chase is the more um you know
the better known vampire serial killer
and the weird thing about it is I'm not
really sure why this guy before they
caught him
like they the media gave him like all
these uh you know crazy nicknames the
Cape Cod vampire the Cape Cod cannibal
even though
well he didn't really eat any of the
people although there were stories that
there was like bite marks on them
um I think Tony Chop Chop that was
another thing they called him but yeah
he had like all these [__] names and
stuff I'm not really sure where the
vampire
thing came from because he didn't really
drink their blood necessarily I think it
was from the bite marks I guess Chase
literally thought he was a vampire yeah
that's what I mean and so I kind of so I
see that obviously because he literally
thought he was a vampire and he if he
didn't have blood he was gonna die yeah
he was a disorganized killer with a
bunch of yeah he was in that case yeah a
bunch of psychotic delusions he was
Not only was the event Not only was he a
vampire he was a Nazi vampire
which is the worst kind of walk around
an old U.S army jacket with uh 22 pistol
break into people's houses shoot shoot
the women
kill the babies drink the blood he's
sopping up blood out of yogurt cups and
[__]
he thought his insides were turned into
powder and he kept just telling the
telling the doctors that his uh either
his stomach or his heart was upside down
I don't remember yeah that's right he
thought he was falling apart yeah but he
was uh
it was funny as he kind of looked like a
damn demented dirty [__] Peter Murphy
in a way
he did rather yeah like Peter Murphy I
always thought he looks very much like
Peter Murphy from from uh Bauhaus yeah
like yeah
man it looks like [__] Peterborough
it did it's like Peter Murphy on crack
it really did like like yeah I was gonna
say Peter Murphy on math yeah oh wait
he's on death he's not correct he was
actually on Netflix
[Music]
it's cheap yeah throwing [__] bottles
at the damn audience although yeah I
will tell you I did see I'm on a couple
of like Peter Murphy fan groups on
Facebook and stuff and uh I did see a
recent picture of him and he's looking
pretty good he looks like he's got his
[__] together so I don't know did he get
a facelift or did he just come off drugs
I'm not sure but he just he doesn't talk
about getting faces it [__] 20 years
ago he does look a lot better never got
around to it he doesn't look a lot
better
so uh so I hope he does man I [__] I
liked Murphy's work I did too um he was
an [__]
he was [__] a lot he was an [__]
to Sonya
friend of ours dated him yeah he's just
you know he's an [__]
so but you know yeah and his drugs
mostly uh well a lot of a lot of um
creative people are [__] well not a
lot of them I guess but and a lot of
famous people are I don't think it'd
have been that bad if it wasn't for the
drugs I think drugs made it worse yeah
I'm sure
he had like a well he had like a little
bit of an arrogance issue I feel not
enough ass beatings
[Laughter]
you get away with a lot of [__] if
you're fans are about a bunch of Goths
you can throw [__] at him and they'll
put up with it and [__] take their
phones he was taking phones and [__] out
of people's hands and making girls cry
at the [__] man I was and I was like
man if that was my girlfriend you just
took her phone I'll come out there and
beat you [__] him
you need all the security
[__] 150 pound ass and get stopped
right in front of the [__] crowd
don't take people's [__] phones yeah
that's [__] up because I'd earned golf
points off that I'd be more of them
ass because somebody stole Jenny's phone
yeah I would earn Mega golf points
the golf dude that beat me to beat meter
Peter Murphy taking his girlfriend's
phone
you got all kinds of points actually
your wife's phone now yeah yeah his
girlfriend he thought that was my
girlfriend yeah because he took it from
her and then looked at me like what are
you gonna do about it right nothing I
don't know that girl
I don't know who that is like
it's all right
smashed the [__] knot in his ass
snatched a knot yeah it's a snatching
[__] so bad that it puts a knot
into them
hospitals Gotta Get It untied
that's pretty fast yeah [__] Peterson
yeah well no but I hope he gets help
that's good that he's uh better because
he he did some [__] good work man he
can write some badass lyrics I mean I
give a man credit where credit is good
where Chris do when he was young he was
a good looking dude I'm super good
looking oh yeah super good super hot
like back in the year he let himself
slide though and drugs and into the 90s
he was still pretty hot like in the late
night good looking for a long time he
did yeah because I saw him in 1998 and
he was still very hot then no excuse
though he could he could have been like
Bowie and been good looking until he
[__] died yeah but we had cat was
died of cancer still looked good yeah
we can't all be Bowie but yeah we can
all aspire to be Bowie yeah that's what
I always Bowie's the model he is yeah
yeah all men should look learn from him
you have to do the same way but you
should just learn how he did yeah you
got to do you like your own version of
them Mr 88 says I've never heard of this
fella either yeah I had never had it
also
um and then somebody said uh yeah and
then he also said Chase is still
regarded by the FBI as the perfect
example of someone who should not be
tried due to Insanity yeah because he
did genuinely believe it seemed like
because like you know yeah you can tell
when people are faking it they're trying
to get an insanity defense and stuff and
usually they don't fall for that [__]
because it's really really hard to get
an insanity defense you have to be
really [__] out there but yeah Chase
was like really [__] out there he
really did believe that his blood was
turning to powder and stuff yes
schizophrenia yeah big time yeah big
time
yeah so a lot of other people have not
heard of this guy either Miss radiates
Jin then says I saw Kurt Vonnegut speak
shortly before he passed oh that's
awesome I know we're going to see him uh
shook his hand I think I've read like
all his books
um Alice in Wonderland Alice in
Wonderland said uh Jenny's saying this
all while drinking is suspicious red
drink yeah it's um cranberry juice yeah
cranberry [__] I promise no it really is
cranberry juice it's actually cranberry
pineapple yeah with vodka in it Ocean
Spray Ocean Spray [__] yeah that's some
good [__] try the cranberry pineapple
it's better than cranberry yeah it still
tastes like cranberry it doesn't taste
like pineapple I don't I don't taste
anything just tastes like cranberry yeah
just doesn't have that weird bitter
aftertaste
yeah
um let's see okay
I can taste the pineapple yeah when you
think about it yeah
all right so do you want to get into
this case we'll talk about yeah we got
this [__] all right let's talk
about it this [__]
so all of these crimes happens pretty
much in I don't know if I'd call this
like a spree or a rampage but they
happened like in a pretty brief period
of time you know what I mean like a year
a year and a half something like that
like 1968 to 1969 right
and this pretty much all happened in an
area called Province Town which is on
Cape Cod which is in Massachusetts if
you're not from here uh which prior to
this pretty quiet place
um and particularly Province Town in the
late 1960s was kind of a mecca for like
um artistic type people uh so it was
kind of like you know if you couldn't go
to like New York City or you know hate
Ashbury in San Francisco or something
like that like during the whole hippie
thing
um a lot of them went to you know so
there was like a lot of transient uh
stuff going on so like the hippie
subculture was big because there was
like nothing going on otherwise but as
far as I know it had been I don't know
if it started out as an artist Colony
but it was very much like that and it's
like even if you see pictures of it
nowadays it still looks like a very like
quaint New England kind of Arty funky
kind of area I've never been there but
you know what I mean that's what it
looks like from the photos
so um yeah so this whole thing started
they actually ended up finding four
bodies uh in the woods like behind a
cemetery in a place called Truro and um
that's kind of what started this whole
[__] thing going now at the time they
found the bodies they didn't know who
the killer was obviously uh so as I said
that's when the media started coming up
with these names like Cape Cod vampire
Cape Cod cannibal stuff like that some
of it is based on things that were maybe
exaggerated I'm not sure if the if the
um bodies having bite marks on them was
exaggerated I don't think so but I do
think this stuff about like hearts being
removed and stuff like that that was
exaggerated but because there were bite
marks so a lot of people we started
calling a vampire or cannibal or
whatever bikes are actually pretty
common in these uh they are yeah yeah so
that's not that weird to me that it's
like because a lot of serial killers do
that connection that's and that's how
they ended up catching oh
bunny
dead body
no it wasn't him yeah yeah he lined up
the bite bar so the Wim the girls that
he bit in the sorority right isn't that
isn't that what they how they got oh
um I think so yeah yeah
he's made a dental impression on him
right he put it over those bruise marks
and it lined up and I think that I think
that's how they got him so when he
killed those girls in that sorority
yeah that's right bit one of them on the
booty yeah she must have had one of them
Peach booties or an apple booty
or maybe the dude was just gonna bite it
whatever whatever it looks like yeah
baby
don't be weird Tom she's dead
the girl is Buckeye a bit Yeah I think
she was dead at the time that's well no
but I'm just like that's that's kind of
[__] up right Kevin says uh I've been
there my family lives on the cape in uh
West Bar is the barn stable or
Barnstable
p-town is cool after this episode I
think I'll stay away oh but this was a
long time ago this was like back in the
60s so you're probably fine and this
dude spoiler alert is dead because
um he was only in prison they put him in
prison in 1970 I believe he was only in
there for four years and he hanged
himself
he was 29 years old because he I guess
he couldn't hack it so you know what I
mean no future
yeah well they put him in there for life
like I said yeah guys like this they
like to have control and they can't have
oh big time this dude is one of the is
probably like the platonic ideal event
yeah he's kind of like he's one of those
dudes which we'll get into in a bit but
he's one of those dudes where he's
always gonna date like teenage girls
like when he's in his 20s because he
likes to be smarter than them and he
likes him to be submissive and all this
other kind of crap so it's that kind of
stuff
so this [__] Tony Costa his name
is actually Antone
a-n-t-n-o-n-e that's not Anthony I well
see I thought it was Anthony but then
like I because that looks like Anthony
to me or Anthony
yeah
um but it doesn't have a it doesn't have
a
a thing or Anton no maybe you could
pronounce it but then I was watched a
couple documentaries about him and they
were saying Antone and I was like that
doesn't sound right but I don't sound
right but anybody everybody called him
Tony anyway so that's what I'm gonna
call him too so he was born in 1944. now
he was just a baby
and his dad died in World War II like I
think he drowned or something somehow
not really sure
now so he didn't really know his dad now
The Story Goes and I'm guessing that
this is uh that his mom told this story
but when the kid was seven years old
this kid told his mom that this man
would come into his room at night and
when he saw a picture of his dad
um that's who he said was coming in his
room so they're leading you to believe
that it's like his dad was like haunting
him or some [__] like that or he was
just making up stories like when he was
uh when he was seven
so this kid
it seemed like like a lot of serial
killers
um there were red flags
pretty much from when he was like a
teenager right
the first thing that he actually got in
trouble for
um you know when he was younger he was
willing to like Taxidermy and weird [__]
like that so we'll get into that a
little bit too but the first thing that
he actually got caught for
this happened in November of 1961 he was
17 years old
and he broke into this apartment in
Somerville Massachusetts
and he broke into this teenage girls
bedroom
and like hovered over her bed like
lurked over her bed like that
and she woke up and started screaming
and he ran away
three days after that though he broke
into the same place
and Drug her out of bed and tried to
drag her down the stairs of her like
apartment building right but the
neighbors of course like heard her
yelling and they came and be like what
the [__] are you doing there I don't
know I don't know where her parents were
but a bunch of people like uh intervened
and so uh and so they kept him there
until the cops got there now he tried to
claim that this was uh oh this is a game
that I play with this girl all the time
totally consensual right
nobody bought that though and I'm sure
the girl was like what the [__] are you
talking about um you just came and
dragged me out of bed you [__]
um yeah so no one bought it so he
actually got charged with burglary and
assault
um he was a minor at the time so he only
got three years probation a one-year
suspended sentence
he was 17.
um and also during this time during his
teenage years how old was that girl I
think she was 12 or 13. something like
that yeah he tried to abduct a raver uh
yeah obviously it was gonna kill her
yeah and then he said oh I come over
here all the time and tie her up she's
into it yeah and everybody's like yeah
right I don't think so
I don't think so
so kind of raising its head in him
already yeah yeah
but like I said he might have done some
[__] before this but this was the first
thing that was like on record because
because he got caught
also supposedly right before this time
like when he was a teenager and stuff
um he was reportedly I brought this up
before like a babysitting like neighbor
kids and stuff like that and all the
kids [__] loved him like a couple of
the people said that yeah he was like
the best babysitter they had like he
would come over and he would hang out
with the kids and like talk to them and
he took him to the park and all this
other kind of [__] and like the kids
just loved him to death which is like
really really weird to think about one
of the people that he babysat which was
um a girl named Liza Rodman she actually
later wrote a book about this like and
it's called the babysitter in my Summers
with a serial killer and she absolutely
never suspected that anything was amiss
with this dude at all she just thought
he was like super cool which is like uh
pretty creepy and he apparently babysat
like a lot of kids in the neighborhood
controlled environment yeah he can't do
anything to the kids because he'd be a
suspect
yeah and um he's compartmentalized yeah
where he's being good to the kids that's
his job and he's enjoying that
it's not really crossing over into his
weird fetishes I guess yeah
so what's funny is that
some people would say well he's
pretending to be a good guy no that's
probably who he was that was one of his
compartments
but he had another compartment yeah
working real hard in him you know and he
was separated it kind of like BTK
yeah you could go to church and it's
cubing yeah that's what he that's what
he called it yeah that just means
putting it in a [__] in a different
box in a different box yeah it's all
compartmentalized yeah he didn't yeah he
didn't use that terminology but that's
what he meant that's what he meant
though yeah yeah and I thought that
might be
um you might have something there
because this guy and I don't know if
this guy was just like bullshitting or
whatever but like after he got caught
um he tried to justify it by saying that
it was either a different dude that did
the stuff like a friend of his that of
course they could never find or it was
like an alter ego type of thing yeah you
know what I mean so it might be it might
be something to do with it might be a
BTK kind of situation
so this book that I read about this guy
uh which is called Helltown it's by
Casey Sherman and this is a quote from
that book
um about his childhood and Adolescence
it says Tony Costa was fascinated by a
Taxidermy as an adolescent and had a
love-hate relationship with his mother
which he then projected onto his victims
for anybody that's seen uh the film
psycho Costa was the living Norman Bates
he also said Tony Costa was the most
brutal serial killer since Jack the
Ripper I studied the autopsy photos I've
studied the crime scene photos these
women were shot they were stabbed
slashed and dismembered there's a real
brutality here that Tony Costa projected
onto these women and I think it all goes
back to his relationship with his mother
in his opinion he said after his father
died during World War II Tony Costa
wanted to keep his mother all to himself
like I said very Norman Bates but his
mother got remarried his mother had
another child and I think the love that
she had to provide to those two other
people in her life created a void and
Costa's heart and brain that's his
opinion uh by the way but that was like
from the book that I thought was like
really interesting like I said that is
very very Norman batesy and I know
Norman Bates is a fictional character
but that's kind of similar to
to what this dude's deal is I also want
to say too and I actually thought this
was really interesting but the book
Helltown focuses a lot on
um Kurt Vonnegut and also on Norman
mailer because both of both of those
writers like lived on Cape Cod at the
time that this was going on and both of
them were really really uh interested in
it and wrote a lot about it like Kurt
Vonnegut wrote an article for Life
Magazine I think in 1969 about him and
he also corresponded with Tony Costa
after Costa got arrested Norman mailer
um based well I think Loosely like based
his 1984 novel tough guys don't dance on
this case uh that was later turned into
a movie in 1987 so both of the writers
were like really interested in that so
there is like a lot of stuff about Kurt
Vonnegut and Norman mailer like in this
book because they both lived there and
they were like really really into it at
the time because this was like a huge
even even though people have kind of
largely forgotten about it now this was
like a huge case like back in the late
60s
now Costa actually got married in April
of 1963.
his wife
um
the girl that he married was 14.
um and he was uh much older he was 23 or
something he was oh he was in his 20s
and he married a girl who was 14 years
old which uh you know tracks that's kind
of on brand for him
and he actually ended up fathering three
children while the two of them were
together so he actually did have kids
I don't know what happened to them
afterward but yeah
um at this point
like a lot of people in the late 1960s
well this was the mid-1960s but uh you
know started taking drugs and [__] like
that and uh it's funny because this one
right up I saw was like uh drugs
complicated the relationship I'm like
I'm pretty sure this dude was probably
like a loon before the drugs happened so
it's like let's not blame the drugs here
entirely but um but yeah I'm sure that
didn't help is is what I'm saying
so a few years after this in June of
1966 he actually brings home to hippie
girls like I said he was very into the
Counter Culture at the time uh their
names were Bonnie Williams and Diane
federoff
and he said that he was going to drive
them to Pennsylvania and then he was
going to keep driving and he was going
to go to California like by himself he
was going out to San Francisco
now after he got caught
he actually
um told the police that he had taken
these two girls to Hayward California
with him even though he said he was
going to drop him off in Pennsylvania
however they never got to wherever they
were supposed to get to so for a long
time people thought that these two girls
were his first two victims because they
didn't know where they were for like a
really long time however I should note
because there are a couple of write-ups
about Tony Costa on the internet that
say that yeah these two girls were
probably his first victims that is not
the case they actually did later find
them and they were fine they were alive
and well so I guess he did actually give
them a ride to wherever they were going
or whatever and they just kind of fell
off the map for a little while but they
did find them later on
um there is another victim that he
supposedly was responsible for that was
also later found alive and that was a
girl named Barbara Spalding who is
actually his girlfriend uh and lived
with him I believe in California for a
little while in 1967 and then again like
fell off the grid for a little while and
they didn't know where she was so for a
long time they thought that he had
killed her as well but later on they did
find her alive so if you see
um sometimes like they'll say that oh he
killed like eight people they're
counting these three women and as far as
as far as I know those three women were
still alive so he didn't kill them I
mean I'm just I'm not saying that it's
good because I'm pretty sure he killed
five people but he didn't kill those
three women that he got accused of
because they were all okay
another thing that happened kind of
earlier on like or before his Killing
Spree started if you want to call it
that and this happened in August of
1967. now he was apparently out hiking
in the woods in Toronto like in
Massachusetts with a girl and he shot
her in the back with an arrow like with
a bow and arrow
and he got away with it because he said
that it was an accident
which I kind of doubt considering all
the [__] that happened later on didn't
kill her though no it didn't kill her
she like she did survive and he was just
like oh whoopsie I'm sure he was
probably trying to kill her and then
when she didn't die he's just like oh
silly me Butterfingers you know what I
mean I kind of feel like that was what
he tried to pull
now here's where it gets a little worse
because
a week after that incident
where he shot the girl with the arrow
um there is an 18 year old girl named
Cindy monzon I think is how you
pronounce her last name I'm not entirely
sure
she actually disappeared uh from her
home in Provincetown
now her uh disappearance was reported to
the police on June 14th
now uh she was missing for quite a while
nobody knew where she was
Now by this time Costa had divorced his
teenage wife
um and had got a new live-in girlfriend
whose name was Susan Perry she was also
a teenager and if you see pictures of
her
she looks it she looks like a child I
mean I think she was only 13 or 14 years
old damn he moves her into the house
and calls her his kid chick
okay
the thing about this dude in the state
that he was in I don't know like I kind
of feel like maybe not but I mean he did
marry a girl when she was 14 which I
always thought you needed parental
permission for that he might have gotten
that maybe he did I mean it was
Massachusetts I don't know if like 14
that seems kind of and I know it was the
60s maybe the age of consent was lower
but yeah I remember in I remember in
Mississippi
um in the 80s and in the 90s you know
when I was growing up there you know
visiting my dad and stuff
age of consent was like 14. yeah and I
think you could marry a 13 year old girl
with PR with with uh
with permission yeah permission this is
these are like laws from
probably the 1800s yeah they're like
they just didn't really change them they
didn't care to change them I don't think
I don't think there was many people
marrying people at 13. they just didn't
worry about it so maybe they just didn't
bother us Junior probably stayed like
that for a long time yeah and then it
probably went to where you could marry
one as 16 without
parental permission is probably still
like that I think most I'm not entirely
sure but I think most States it's 16 is
when you can marry without permission
but some states might be 18 I'm not
entirely sure but I think 16 is pretty
common yeah people get bent out of shape
about this 18 thing oh she was under 18.
it only matters if she's under 18 if
you're shooting porn people get this
confused that's not age of consent
you in Most states age of consent is
like 16. it's usually 16. and then
it's illegal if it's a teacher
or if it's somebody like an authority
figure yeah but if it's not anybody
directly connected like 16 is usually
the age of consent just across the board
more or less
I mean I'd have to look into each state
but yeah 18 and here's the thing
let's say you married that chick at 16.
and you're 19. if you take a nude
photograph of her technically that would
be child porn yes it would you you could
go to Serious even though you're married
to her right
so you know you can't do you can't take
any pictures of anybody nude
you know unless it's like you know
little kids you know parents taking
pictures of their shoes at the beach or
something yeah they're on the beat yeah
it's not the same intent yeah right yeah
obviously right
but you know
so people get hung up on this 18th they
don't they don't know the loss and it
varies state by state
but usually in general it's like 16 is
age of consent yeah I think that's
usually like pretty common so I don't
really know like how this dude was
allowed to like marry a 14 year old but
like I said maybe maybe he got consent
from the parents because that's the
thing about this [__] and I
think this is true of a lot of
psychopaths of this ilk is that they are
very superficially charming and this
dude did seem to be like that now a lot
of people did say that he seemed a
little bit off but on the surface he
seemed like pretty Charming he was
actually like pretty okay looking
um as it went on like later on like he
always had drugs
so he never had problems getting girls
like especially younger girls
um like I said because he had drugs
because he paid attention to them uh
because he seemed intelligent and
philosophical and [__] like that he was
kind of able to
manipulate them into
relationships with him and kind of I
don't want to say that he almost had
it was almost like a Manson type thing
that he had over them like they called
him sire
okay like they called him that and I was
just like are you [__] kidding me
right now but yeah so it's just kind of
like but they were you know they were
much younger than he was but I think he
enjoyed like having this flock of like
teenage girls yeah like fawning over him
and hanging on his every word and like
looking for
instructions I guess well he's in his
like late teens or 20s at this point
right all right
that's what I mean sorry I just I
laughed at this because white people
says BTK to-do list one pick up donuts
for church social two go over clove
hitches at Scout meeting three so
goldfish into neighbor's stomach
he did that he didn't do that
that's like pretty [__] funny
it's so goldfish in a neighbor's stomach
that's pretty awesome
um but yeah
so uh
so he gets this girlfriend Susan Perry
who like I said I think she was only 13
and she moves in with him
um you know and he calls her the kid
chick
and she lived with him thank you thank
you Dermot thank you thank you thank you
belated congratulations to you both uh
greetings from my vacation in Ireland oh
I hope you're having a good vacation
that sounds like super fun but yeah
thank you very much yeah I forgot like
you haven't been here in a little while
but yeah in case you in case you're new
here or you weren't here like when we
announced that me and Tom got married
last
week well was it last week yeah it was
last Thursday September 14th that's when
we went but yeah so uh so thank you very
much that's really nice Tom will thank
you when he gets back he's put more ice
in this [__] right now
but yeah so this girl moves in with him
and she apparently lives there
for a week
and then she also disappeared this was
on September 10th was I believe the last
time that anyone saw her alive
now a couple people did ask where she
had gone it's like Hey where's that
teenage girl you had living here I can't
imagine the conversation
um and he said that she had gone to
Mexico
now I will note that because this is the
late 1960s you know it's a time of like
a lot of cultural upheaval and things
like that and I've written about a lot
of serial killers that
preyed on people during this time period
taking advantage of the fact that a lot
of people were like I said transient or
runaways or you know everybody that was
into the counterculture was like oh
we're gonna go to San Francisco or we're
going to go to New York City or
something like that so I do kind of feel
like if they were teenagers and they
just ran off
um a lot of times they didn't it didn't
get reported because their parents were
like ah damn hippies they just went off
and did something and you know what I
mean so I kind of feel like when Susan
Perry disappeared and he told everybody
that she had just gone to Mexico
a lot of people didn't really question
it all that much they're like oh yeah I
suppose they do those things even though
she was just like a teenager but it was
very common for teenagers to be like
running away and [__] like that but like
I said serial killers at that time like
took advantage of that too because
people were just going Here There and
Everywhere and their families didn't
know where they were for like a really
long time
so there was that
now in mid-september so only
um probably like just a few days after
uh Susan Perry went missing
uh Tony Costa got arrested for you got
pulled over and he got arrested for
driving with a suspended license
um and he was you know kind of taken in
but then he was like let go
now a few days after that probably like
a week or two after that on the 25th of
September
he got picked up again uh because he
wasn't paying uh child support to his
you know uh former wife and children
because he they had divorced at this
point
uh so they actually kept him in custody
until November 8th
now when they let him out he started
hanging around with this other young
woman whose name was Christine gallant
and she was another person that had come
there because of the whole burgeoning
hippie thing and so they were hanging
out and doing drugs together
now in late November
Christine Gallant was found dead in her
apartment in New York now at first it
seemed that she had died of a um
overdose of barbiturates that she had
drowned in her bathtub
um so at the time everyone thought
because nobody knows that Tony Costa is
a serial killer at this point right so
they're just saying oh well it was an
accidental overdose she took a bunch of
drugs and then got in the tub and then
she drowned and it happens all the time
and it was an accident however like
after Tony Costa got caught they kind of
like started to look back and go oh well
maybe that wasn't an accident you know
what I mean or maybe he was there like
they did find out that he was probably
there when that happened so you know
that's a little suspicious now as I said
um
Tony Costa was superficially a very
Charming person some people thought that
he was a little bit off he was a little
bit of a loner
um he had like a weird way of talking
where it seemed as though he was trying
to come across as like a lot more
intelligent than maybe he actually was
you know what I mean he had like a very
flowery kind of way of talking
um but because he became a drug dealer
and always had drugs like he was always
pretty popular like in the hippie scene
he would eventually actually have his
own marijuana Garden uh which again made
him quite popular because he always was
the guy that had the weed right
um and as I said he always liked to hang
out with much younger girls who
generally called him sire also yeah as
soon as like I read that I was like oh
my God you have got to be [__]
kidding me right now like if the people
call him that like with a straight face
if you [__] ask me to call you that I
would hit you right in your face yeah
like you asking her [__] to call
you Lord
I'm like no no I'm not doing that
you really only called so you can really
only expect to call
can understand that
yeah yeah I mean
I'm not calling anybody I'm not calling
anybody in that stupid [__] you know
what I'm saying I'm just not
like don't try to [__]
don't try to like pull rank on me
[__] you know I'm just saying
it's not it's not gonna work so so yeah
um
also I should note
that Tony Costa was a police informant
so he was able to one I guess I don't
know if they knew that he was dealing
drugs or not but if they did they were
just kind of like ah whatever like
because I guess he would like give them
information about other ones and they
were like okay so we'll let your [__]
slide also once he started killing
people he seemed like he was kind of
able to keep tabs on what law
enforcement were doing because he you
know had an in with them so there was
that too like I don't know how many of
his friends knew that he was a police
informant but he was
now on January 24th 1969.
uh two young women named Patricia Walsh
and Mary Ann wysocki they actually
disappeared while they were on a visit
to Provincetown
now these two were actually they weren't
transient they weren't anything like
that they were just uh there for the
weekend like for a vacation
uh they were actually from Providence
Rhode Island
one of them was a college student she
was like finishing out her degree the
other one was actually a second grade
teacher I believe it was second grade it
was elementary school anyway
um now they ended up staying in the same
guest house as Tony Costa was uh staying
now he had actually come there a short
time before and actually I believe got a
cheap rate on a room because he told the
landlady that he was a carpenter which
he was and so he would do things around
the building like fix stuff you know for
for free room aboard essentially
so these two young women ended up
staying at this just completely randomly
um ended up staying at the same guest
house as him
so he kind of befriended them
and as I said they were only there for a
couple of days and so Tony Costa left a
note on their door
asking them if they could give him a
ride to Truro the next day
so they said that they would
however
um after they after he got in the car
with them
uh they were never seen alive again
the day after that another note uh that
actually appeared on the landlady's door
and this was supposedly from the two
women saying oh you know thank you for
the hospitality we checked out blah blah
however it should be noted that
Marianne's name was spelled wrong yeah
Marianne like her aunt had an e on the
end and this one did not
so a little bit fishy a little bit fishy
now these two disappearances unlike The
Disappearance of Susan from earlier
were reported pretty much immediately
um because these two women were expected
back at their jobs and back at their
classes you know what I mean and their
families were like yeah they wouldn't
just skip out you know what I mean it's
like they had jobs and responsibilities
and stuff and they had only gone to Cape
Cod like for the weekend they just kind
of went for a little vacation or
whatever and they were expected to come
back and get back to work
now not long after this
Pat Walsh's Volkswagen
was found parked at this old Cemetery
called Pine Grove Cemetery like it was
kind of parked behind there and because
this was kind of a small town and there
was you know all the locals everybody
knew everybody and they were just like
look we don't recognize this car and we
don't understand why anybody would leave
this car abandoned here so it was
reported like pretty quickly
now the cops started searching this area
on February 8th
and underneath a tree they knew to look
under there because there was like
pieces of rope like kind of around the
tree a little bit just like scraps of
rope and it looked like it had like red
on the Rope so they thought that was
pretty suspicious
so they started digging under this
particular tree
under this tree they found a set of
dismembered remains a body cut into
eight pieces I believe the first thing
they found was a bag with a severed head
in it because I watched the um
the interview with like the the cop that
had found it was like the first one on
the scene
now interestingly because like I said
they were searching this area because
they were looking for these two missing
women right that have been staying at
this guest house
but these remains did not belong to
either Patricia Walsh or Marianne
wysocki the two women they were looking
for
these remains actually belonged to Susan
Perry who as I mentioned had been
missing since the previous Labor Day she
was the girl that had been staying with
him like as his kid chick his girlfriend
uh these these were her remains
now a month after they found uh they
found that
they also found a head and a torso that
belonged to Marianne wysocki uh they
found this in a big hole like not far
from uh this plot where Tony Costa had
like his where he was growing marijuana
previously
not long after that they found the rest
of Marianne wysaki's body and they also
found Pat Walsh's remains
now all of the remains had been horribly
mutilated
uh with a knife they had probably died
from gunshot wounds but they had been
cut up they had been dismembered um
particularly like their breasts had been
cut off uh one of them had her I believe
had her uh uterus removed things like
that
um underneath these two bodies they also
found another body a dismembered uh
remains of Sydney monzon who was like
the first one to disappear
she was 18.
um so these three women had all been
buried in Shallow Graves this was about
a mile and a half from where they found
Susan Perry first of all because like I
said they expanded the uh the search and
ended up finding these other three
bodies coroner also reported that he had
found evidence of necrophilia so when
you specify what is it no he did not see
him in some way that's well yeah I'm
imagining that's probably what it was
um
that old Telltale semen
y'all get that [__] everywhere yeah
never know where that's gonna end up
laughs
oh my God yeah I mean that's [__] that's
[__] up
that's [__] up
so obviously uh the discovery of these
of four bodies
in Cape Cod was like a big deal because
like I said this is a very low crime
area very chill like everybody knew
everybody and [__] like that so
everybody was kind of freaking out now I
will note though that the district
attorney whose name was Edmund Dennis
he was the one that kind of exaggerated
the [__] somewhat
and probably made it a much bigger media
you know uh Onslaught than it maybe
would have been otherwise I don't know
it's pretty horrific anyway but like he
added like all these details like he
added the detail one of the things that
he said when they interviewed him they
did a press conference right
and he said the hearts of each girl have
been removed from the bodies and were
not in the graves nor were they found
this was not true
um also he said a razer-like device was
found near the graves also not true each
body was cut into as many parts as there
are joints
um the bodies were dismembered that's
true
um but they weren't cut into as many
pieces as he's maybe implying you know
what I mean like the first body they
found was cut into eight pieces so
that's not like a huge exaggeration and
like I said the fact that like hearts
cut out and stuff that wasn't true but
it wasn't that much of an exaggeration
because yes like a couple of the like at
least one of the victims had some of
their organs removed and like taken and
then they didn't find them
so it's an exaggeration but not that big
an exaggeration uh so yeah
um like that yeah and like I said they
didn't find like a razor-like device or
anything next to them or nothing like
that I don't think they found any kind
of murder weapon at all
um but because of this press conference
and the [__] that he said about it it
made it into not just a national story
but like an international story so it's
like there's press from everywhere and
they just like kind of came to Cape Cod
and uh you know and a bunch of like
tourists started coming so they could
like you know look at the [__] and
everything like that
and as I said it was around this time
that they started
um giving this serial killer
silly like names Cape Cod Casanova that
was another one that I didn't remember
yeah Tony Chop Chop or did they just
call them Chop Chop at first but then
like later when they found out who he
was then they called him Tony jab jab
but yeah Cape Cod cannibal Cape Cod
vampire that's been really giving them
all these names right
now Tony Costa
didn't actually become a suspect until
after law enforcement figured out that
the marijuana patch because it was like
a pretty big like Garden where he was
growing marijuana
um they found out that it was his that
he was the one that was growing it there
and that was like right where near where
the bodies were found
also uh when they delved into witness
reports and things like that uh they
were able to determine that this
[__] had been seen with all four
of the Dead women prior to them
disappearing which again that's a little
suspicious
also they recovered this dumbass's
fingerprints from the owner's manual of
Pat Walsh's Volkswagen which had been
abandoned in the cemetery which was what
made them look in the like start digging
around there in the first place so
there's that wear gloves you know that's
a rookie mistake
um also as I said they discovered that
Pat Walsh and Marianne wysaki have been
staying at the same
uh in where Tony Costa was staying and
when they searched his room they found
the girl's Luggage in his closet which
again very suspicious now they asked him
well why are your fingerprints in their
car like why do you have their car he
said
that Pat had sold the car to him and
brought out this piece of paper that
said I Patricia Walt sell this car to
you for 900 or whatever the [__] and uh
yeah and then he said yeah they just
sold me the car and then they went to
Canada
again
think of a better story than that
[__] Jesus Christ that's like
and of course the cops didn't buy that
so they arrested this dumbass and they
brought him in
for questioning
so they give him a polygraph test he
fails it
and he tries to tell them all these
different stories and justifications
about what exactly was going on
um but of course he couldn't keep them
all straight he kept like contradicting
himself and [__] like that
so
um they have they gave him a psychiatric
evaluation
and the first psychiatrist that looked
into him
said that he had a schizoid personality
a couple months later they brought in
another psychiatrist to assess him and
this one called Tony Costa a modern day
Marquis De Assad which is uh something
also called him a sexually dangerous man
and that he was absolutely capable of
murder
so there's that as well
so this dude's Garden like I said his
marijuana patch where they found the
bodies and [__] like that ended up
becoming a kind of a tourist attraction
because you know it's we love the True
Crime [__] and it's like you're gonna go
see where this [__] happens you know
what I mean so they said they had all
these tourists like go out in these
Woods in Truro where he had been growing
pot and they started like digging around
because they were like looking ooh maybe
we'll find some body parts that the cops
didn't find and [__] like that I'm like
how exactly would you feel if you went
out there and actually did find a
[__] body part I don't think you feel
too good about it like the idea of it
maybe sounds cool like when you're
thinking about it but when you actually
find it I imagine it's probably not that
cool I imagine it's probably pretty
horrible but um but yeah
also there were kind of rumors going
around some of which still persist to
this day that there was like a satanic
worship and all this other kind of [__]
which may be kind of tied in with like
some [__] that he did later when he was
in prison
now
here's another thing that this
[__] did because I kind of feel
like this type of dude this type of
killer
they always seem one they always seem
like super arrogant like they think
they're smarter than everybody
which this dude absolutely was not
because he got killed he got caught
not immediately but it didn't take him
that long to catch him because it's not
like he was trying to [__] hide it or
anything like that and like then the
stories that he came up with for why why
do you have this car and why your
fingerprints in it and why this and that
and the other thing and he always came
up with these really dumb [__]
justifications he sounds like he's doing
it on impulse yeah maybe yeah maybe I'm
just saying that it's just like he he
doesn't sound like the sharpest tool in
the shed is all I'm saying
um but yeah
so he wrote This Book
like a novel
which has never been published and it
was called Resurrection
and this novel he actually it's a
fictionalized version of the murders
which again if you want people to think
you're innocent that's probably the not
the best course of action is to write a
fictional novel saying yeah I totally
did that [__] or someone like me totally
did that [__] but that's kind of what he
did
now in his novel
he said that he had a friend named Corey
and this friend they were out um him and
Corey his imaginary friend were out with
these two women that he was convicted of
killing
um Pat Walsh and Mary and waithaki
and said they were out in the woods and
they were doing LSD and like some other
drugs and [__] like that and then
suddenly out of nowhere
Corey shot the two girls
Tony Costa is shocked by this why why
would you do such a thing
um and then Tony Costa says he jumped on
his friend and like subdued him right
and then he realized that uh Pat Walsh
was dead but that Marianne wysocki was
still alive so he's like well at that
point I took my knife and stabbed her to
end her suffering
that was his [__] story yeah
and that's right bro I'm sticking to it
right that was his [__] story
and then he says and then me and Corey
buried the bodies like so we wouldn't
get caught I'm just like
like I said not coming up with the best
[__]
not coming up with the best [__]
stories yeah buffoon not coming up with
the best [__] stories here
um also
the same novel Resurrection
he describes in great detail uh the
deaths of Susan Perry the teenager who
was living with him and uh Sydney Monson
who was his first victim as far as they
know uh and he says that both of them
died of drug overdoses and he had
absolutely nothing to do with it he just
buried them because they didn't want to
get in his room yeah
um and in this case he says that it was
his alter ego whose name was Carl
um he was the one that dismembered them
and buried them and that he had no idea
what was happening until after it was
all over that's what this [__]
said
okay I'm just like okay
so yeah so they caught the dude like I
said they arrested him and he got
indicted in 1970 for three murders uh
Sydney monzon uh Pat Walsh and Marianne
wysocki
now his trial starts on May 6th 1970.
and uh his defense team
tried to argue because they're like well
we're pretty sure he's going to be found
guilty so we gotta we gotta [__]
soften the blow somehow so they tried to
argue that because of all of his drug
abuse that that had made him like crazy
or you know disconnected from reality or
something like that
however Tony Costa in His Infinite
Wisdom decided that he was going to take
the stand in his own defense
and if his defense team had wanted to
paint him as crazy then this was
um not not a good look because Tony
Costa gets up on the stand and is
completely coherent
and intelligent and articulate so
everyone's like huh well he's obviously
not crazy so he must be a [__]
psychopath because he just came across
as completely normal like he didn't come
across as crazy and like he just I don't
know he just talked like a normal person
and everyone's like all right
so the jury were like all right so
obviously not crazy uh probably a
psychopath
so he actually got he was only um
convicted of two murders he wasn't
convicted of the Sydney monzon murder
I'm not entirely sure why maybe they
didn't have enough evidence in that
regard but he was for sure convicted of
the other two murders
and he got can uh sentenced to life in
prison uh in 1970 in May of 1970. now he
got convicted and he got transferred to
Walpole uh Correctional institution and
while in there got super into the occult
because you know might as well had the
Satanic Bible had all that kind of [__]
and I think that's where a lot of that
kind of satanic stuff like happened
later on
so the motive was sex I'm guessing
um he had all these girls around him
maybe it wasn't sex but they seemed to
be to do this yeah
I mean some are married they go out and
do this
I guess it's yeah I mean he was married
and he had three kids I don't know what
happened to his kids because they were
little yeah like when all this [__] was
going on because like I said all the
killings that he did was like in like a
year period it wasn't like a huge like
teenage girls worship him like a cult
member right like it was very much I it
kind of reminded me of like that whole
Charles Manson thing a little bit like
maybe not to that degree and not for
that length of time
but had this guy not been caught
um I think that probably would have
continued because he did seem to have
like a cult kind of
thing and and they did seem to think
that he was like super Charming at least
superficially and he was just able to
like lure these teenage girls into his
orbit yeah and get them to kind of like
worship him yeah which means he was
having sex with them well yeah I don't
think anyone's denying that so it's like
he
he liked it involved you dying I guess
you getting shot yeah and then you do
[__] up [__] to your body weird
because that definitely like the [__] he
was doing to their bodies
um it didn't seem to me I'm not really
sure but it didn't seem to me that he
was doing you know because like a lot of
serial killers will do like a lot of
torture beforehand because they like to
see the pain and the fear they like they
get off on that
this dude I'm not really sure it seemed
more like he had more of like a
necrophiliac kind of or maybe that was
like the ultimate power over them it's
like after they were dead or after they
were at least incapacitated to a point
where they might as well have been dead
then he seemed to want to have sex with
him then or start dismembering them or
something so and I I think it's kind of
instructive here to say that he was real
into Taxidermy also like even when he
was a teenager like they said he used to
go around
like picking up roadkill and [__] like
that so like I said very much like
Norman Bates kind of [__]
so he could Taxidermy and I'm not saying
that everybody's into Taxidermy is a
serial killer obviously that would be
ridiculous but um it does seem in light
of his later crimes that he was kind of
into that so I think he was almost kind
of like fascinated by
girls and women's bodies as objects to
be like taken apart after they were dead
yeah after they were dead right because
it really did seem like that was his
main motivation I guess
um and it does seem I don't even know
like he did have sex with him apparently
willingly
um at least some of them
prior
um and I but I do think that he had sex
with their bodies like at least in a
couple of instances he wanted total
consumption I guess wanted to be able to
just like yeah totally use them up I
kind of feel like maybe that's what it
was it's like the weird thing it's like
I don't they can't cheat on you yeah you
can't cheat on you yeah you got him
forever something like that
like you said that is kind of similar to
Dahmer yeah no way to lose them that's
that's the way Dahmer was he was like
they were his possessions forever
yeah and you know he would own their
souls in the afterlife and [__] he was
building an altar yeah
I mean it's it's [__] up something
like that yeah
yeah but um but yeah so I put myself
into the shoes you know yeah it's kind
of hard to do like I kind of feel like
this I don't know if this dude had a lot
of
um Insight yeah it could be into his own
behavior not have been all that bright
so he really didn't know why he was
doing it but he was one of those
[__] that thought he was like
super intelligent but to me like his
actions
um
you know demonstrated or that he wasn't
and this and he was a police informant
too so he supposedly had like this in
line with the cops like so he could know
what was going on but so I don't know I
don't know if like you said it might
have just been impulsive yeah some kind
of impulse because he did
it and it's entirely possible that you
know what he said in his book about
having like this Alter Ego named Carl
it's entirely possible that might not be
entirely [__] we see the girl
running from him and he's got a bow and
see he can't he can't help it he has
this impulse to [__] shoot her with
the bow and then later oh it was an
accident
was that Thunder yeah holy [__] yeah
holy [__] wow yeah the storm here yeah
that was scary
it did that sounded like thunder yeah
that didn't sound like a car
but yeah so he gets into like I said the
occult and [__] like that however
he was only in prison
for four years uh when they came around
one day May 12 1974 they found him
hanging in his cell with a leather belt
um and he ended up getting uh buried
near his mom
in an unmarked grave because that's what
they do in Provincetown and um I think
there were some rumors around that
somebody murdered him or something like
that but I'm like even if somebody did
who cares I mean it's not like
it's not like anybody's gonna miss the
[__] right yeah I'm just saying
so it's like but I mean by all accounts
he just killed himself and I and I
imagine it was probably just because
like you said he's in prison now he
can't control his environment anymore
and he couldn't really take it because
he really did seem like somebody that
needed to be in control of everything
yeah you know what I mean
yeah well killing the victim I guess is
total control yeah
then you got him yeah weird weird dude
he is a weird dude
um and I brought up Kurt Vonnegut before
um he actually published he's very
famous novel Slaughterhouse Five uh
which I read in school and probably a
lot of people were in school
um he actually published that at around
the same time that um
Pat Walsh's and uh Mary and wysocki's
remains were found in the woods and as I
said Kurt Vonnegut actually had written
about the murders in Life magazine and
he actually wrote letters back and forth
uh with the dude like while he was in
jail and he called him a modern day Jack
the Ripper now interestingly Kurt
vonnegut's daughter Edith had actually
been friends with Tony Costa
um like you know before anybody knew he
was a killer like he knew later on he's
like um he said
this is what he said he said she met him
during a Crazy Summer she spent on her
own in Provincetown and knew him well
enough to receive and decline an
invitation he evidently extended to many
girls come and see my marijuana patch
yeah
yeah so it's probably good that Edith
was like no no thanks because probably
she would have been killed also but like
I said he seemed to hang out with like a
lot of girls and he didn't kill all of
them so maybe it was kind of like a
weird impulsive thing yeah I don't
really holy [__] yeah that is like a
storm that's really loud yeah that's
gonna storm that's okay though it's like
it's atmospheric yeah that's at the end
of the show anyway well I mean you know
I can't believe we've only been on for
like an hour and 11 an hour and 11
minutes that's 11 minutes longer than
the shows were when we first started
this channel I know right we tried to
keep it in an hour I know but you know
but I like it I like being on like a
little bit longer though because it's
like it's kind of fun but yeah so um
actually if you've seen the American
Horror Story
uh uh season I think it was season 10
which I think was called red tide
um that was kind of loosely sort of
loosely based on this dude kinda because
I think there weren't there like it
would took place in Provincetown and
they shot it there and they were like
these vampire kind of creatures and
stuff so they kind of based on this even
though like I said he's called the Cape
Cod vampire even though he didn't do
anything super vampire other than the
bodies having bite marks on them
but he didn't like eat them or anything
I don't think not that they know of but
like I said he really did seem to have
like a necrophilia kind of [__] going on
but um as I mentioned if you have Kindle
unlimited there's a good book on there
called Helltown
which is about this
um and it kind of goes back and forth
between Tony Costa and I'm gonna say
like a lot of it at least from what I
read a lot of it seemed
I don't want to say fictionalized but
I'm just gonna say he took some artistic
license because there's a lot of like
conversations between Tony Costa and his
potential victims so I'm you know
because he's kind of like laying out the
scenario of what might have happened so
you know obviously you don't know if
that's what the dude really said or what
the victim really said or anything like
that but he's just kind of like using it
to kind of paint a picture in your mind
and he's like I said the way he talks he
kind of extrapolated from the dude's
novel and from his letters and stuff
like that because like I said he had
this weird like stilted kind of Flowery
way of talking because he wanted people
to like think that he was smarter than
he was
you know he was very into oh you know
he's reading all these oh yes I was
reading this Herman Hess and I was doing
you know what I mean he was like that
kind of [__] so um so the the
way that he talks in the book is kind of
what I imagined like he sounded like in
real life like this is [__] overly oh
my God I'm so smart like one of those
well actually [__] like they
probably had a fedora if they had
fedoras like you know what I mean and
then neckbeard is it he kind of reminds
me of that kind of dude but even though
he kind of looks like hit because
everybody looked like a hippie back then
but that's what he looked like and he
was selling drugs to the hippies but
yeah so hell town is really good
um there's another one called in his
garden which is about him but I haven't
read that one so I don't know if that
one's good but like Helton I really I
really liked it but Helltown like I said
there's a lot of [__] in there about
Kurt Vonnegut and Norman mailer as well
so like it goes back and forth between
Tony Costa and the crimes and what
probably happened with all the victims
and stuff and then it goes back and
forth like talking about Kurt Vonnegut
and Norman Baylor what they were doing
at that time and [__] like that because
they were kind of involved in the case
to like some degree and they're famous
people so that's why he was like talking
about it
um so yeah and and like I said if you've
seen
season 10 of um American Horror Story
that's kind of sort of loosely based on
this dude but I don't know if it says
that on the Wikipedia page though
I think I don't know but um I just read
that somewhere so I thought I would
mention it I haven't seen it but I don't
so I don't know how closely it adheres
to the case so there's that
um
oh priest isn't a color bro yeah okay
where okay so now I'm trying to catch up
with all the uh thing oh Zach said that
wasn't Thunder it was just Satan
dragging The Souls of the Damned over
your roof like evil Santa the reindeer
no biggie yeah it was a real first it
was uh it was totally loud it was really
loud it sounded like uh garbage cans or
something wrong yeah yeah it wasn't
though it's raining outside
Mr 88 says I had never heard the term
video nasties until these weirdos named
Jen and Tom did a show on it isn't that
crazy I was like well I knew about it
from the 80s because well one we grew up
in the 80s and I was like real into I'm
I was kind of an anglophile back then so
I knew like all about all this British
[__] so I and I was really into horror
movies so it's like so
even like starting in the 80s I knew all
about like all of the [__]
folder roll that was going on about
[__] video nasties ever than all the
[__] they were Banning and stuff and it
was just so [__] funny to me very
British
it is very British concept
um and it's hilarious because all of
these kind of
upper Upper Crust kind of twit people
they didn't know jack [__] about [__]
horror movies at all
um would just the [__] that got swept up
in the video nasties uh you know the
whole thing it's just some of them were
just so tame or some of them didn't have
anything to do with yeah and then but
then they would let other [__] slide it
was just so [__] random it in that
era our uptight [__] would have been
super upset over the fact that England
had titties they showed yeah newspaper
they would flip their [__] here if there
was it's so strange to me that it's like
it like the UK they were very much into
it's like well we can't have people like
cutting people's heads off and [__] like
that they were more worried about that
which to me is more I I still don't
understand that I still don't want them
to censor it yeah as long as it's not
real
um but that's more understandable to me
over here it's a lot more like
puritanical it's like you can show all
yes you can show
50 bajillion people getting shot yeah
and it's fine you show a tit or a bush
yeah oh my God everybody loses their
[__] mind or you show like a dick and
it's not even erect yeah and even still
like I feel like even now they show a
movie that has like a penis in it and
not an erect penis just a regular ass
penis you know what I mean just hang in
there like like they do and people will
flip their [__] [__] about it I'm
like it's a body part calm down it
wasn't it's not like that now no I know
it's much better exactly but back then
yeah you showed a dick in a movie
everybody heard about that [__] yeah
everybody and actually like tits were
pretty common
um you know especially in horror movies
everybody's like you had a slasher movie
everybody wanted to put tits in there
because then the teenage boys would
watch it but you put you couldn't put
bush in there you couldn't show a vagina
and you for sure could not show a dick
yeah everybody would flip their [__] if
you showed that which to me is just like
really really stupid it's really stupid
yeah it's hard to get porn
yeah that's what that's what those
horror movies were all about and a lot
of those Sci-Fi movies and fantasy
movies for teenage boys is they show
titia yeah yeah and [__] they were
they were piping that [__] in
through cable Cinemax HBO
show time we'd stay up late man during
the summers in our teenage years hanging
out in Mississippi just we knew we would
see we would go through the guide they
had they had that they had guides back
then you know every month when your
cable subscription
we wanted to see which ones had to end
next to it for nudity yeah and if it had
and and next to it we were gonna watch
that and they would write that one down
yeah and that one was always going to be
weekends Friday and Saturday nights late
you know and it was mostly [__] like
Friday the 13th series
[__] uh
uh Galaxy of Terror that had a good one
with a woman getting raped by a [__]
caterpillar a giant caterpillar I mean
that's pretty [__] up even by today's
standards yeah there's all kinds like
just the idea of it I'm just kind of
like right right
and in the culture of the time in North
European it was okay if it was
in a horror theme and there's a bunch of
violence it wasn't seen as erotic right
so you could do it
um even in a horror movie
even though it might be an erotic scene
two people having sex and then they get
killed yeah
well because they're getting punished
right you could get away with it
yeah in those days looking back on it
you know look you know some of my
friends that I talked to online you know
and I lived in the Middle East for a
while a lot of my extended family is
still in the Middle East
um they went there to work as
contractors and stuff
the United States was kind of like it
was almost kind of Islamic in that era
it was kind of yeah it was kind of like
something out of Islam
and uh
you know I might say it's a bad thing
it's just that
when we were kids growing up in it in
the 80s we thought the adults were kind
of [__] crazy yeah they were they
overreacted to everything yeah and they
didn't know [__] like I said they didn't
know [__] about horror movies they
didn't know [__] about heavy metal music
they didn't know [__] about [__] yeah
they'd get UPS up [__] tired about
heavy metal
because you know there might be satanic
themes in it
but they're not [__] paying close
attention to what it's talking about no
it's it's
satanic themes only make sense in a
Christian background
you know you can't be an atheist and
have Satan and Satan was usually a
character you're like watching something
out of the evil dead it's a character in
a movie like you you get a Venom album
it's not about reality yeah you know
it's it's you're like it's like you're
retina a VHS copy of the Evil Dead one
and two
you know what I mean so
it was theatrical Satanism there was a
real Satanism but but adults bought into
it man they were [__] yeah they
thought they were serious yeah but if
kids knew exactly what it was no it's
like a horror movie yeah it's an album
though a whole band with a horror nobody
really believes that [__] yeah
but that's what was so silly about it
it's like I I don't know I just kind of
feel like even
particularly back then they just did not
understand horror movies they didn't
understand why would anybody want to
watch oh well if you want to watch stuff
like that that must mean you want to do
stuff like that I'm like that's not how
it works
at all yeah I got in trouble in junior
high or high school for reading like
Clive Barker and stuff like they sent me
to the guidance counselor yeah it must
be something wrong with you right and
I'm just like she must be disturbed no
but okay what's funny is that for the
most part that generation is is long
gone they're they're they're they're
they're not in power anymore or they're
very old and dying off
and it's just not like that anymore here
um
but you have people that think it's like
that now but it's not it's not anywhere
as bad as it used to be not like you'll
have like gen Z people thinking that
Christian fundamentalists still run
everything no they don't not compared to
the way it was you have no idea I mean
they're still around and they still
whine about this and that and the other
thing but most people don't listen to
them anymore they don't have the power
they used to they don't have the numbers
I've like been there done that
and there you don't see them trying to
shut down pornography you don't see them
trying to shut down [__] music and
[__] they're they're listening they're
then watching all that
it's a different it's a different
[__] era
yeah I'm GL I'm just glad that the
satanic Panic shows yeah satanic panic's
over by the way if you want to see a
really good movie about that era
um well I really liked it anyway your
mileage may vary but it's called sensor
and it's about a woman who worked for
the bbfc like it's not based on anything
real but it's based on the real bbfc so
it's like kind of a bit about a woman
like this real uptight kind of woman
that worked there back in the 80s and uh
I'm not gonna spoil it other than that
but I loved that movie I think that was
like one of my favorite horror films
that I saw like in the last few years it
was so [__] good I was really into it
the satanic Panic people would have been
my grandparents generation maybe a
little bit younger yeah yeah you're
older than my parents
it's just that your parents were caught
up in this [__] yeah because we used to
just laugh our asses like you see him
beyond the talk shows like getting off
getting their panties all in a nod about
[__] heavy metal bands and horror and
the evil dead and everything I'm like
bro have you even like watched that [__]
come on in those days your parents would
have been in their 30s and they might
have kind of bought into it like wow is
that real yeah it's not real no what
they're talking about is not real
they're blown and it's yeah it's not
real Oprah and [__] Geraldo Rivera
yeah all those talk shows all those
people what people were watching it you
know they were the ones responsible for
it now if you if you want to go to Oprah
today and [__] call her out on the
satanic Panic she'd deny it like she was
never there no that [__] was doing
shows on that she was helpful in the
[__] satanic Panic Oprah they all
were they all did it Geraldo Rivera and
[__] yeah Geraldo I think was he was
maybe the worst offender
because he was really trying to yeah
trying to get some like eyeballs on the
[__] right they're walking around
holier than down now
but when they were in their [__] late
30s and 40s they were [__] sellouts
[__] I was there I remember yeah
[__] were sell out I remember yeah
and they knew they were lying Sally
Jesse Raphael she was another one that
had a lot of that stuff on there yeah
they knew they were lying too yeah of
course they knew they were lying well
they like I said they just wanted people
to watch the [__] yeah and you know then
as now uh people are not any different
so anything that's controversial or
crazy or conflict based or something
like that people are gonna watch that
[__] that's just man it's drama they
used to pass around tapes to school
Jenny Jones that was another one they
passed around tapes at a school that
were uh like recordings off a radio
and we used to listen to them there were
shows about backwards masking and yeah I
remember yeah they did whole shows about
that [__] yeah and it was like if you
guys know what that is they were claim
certain people
kind of like religious affiliations were
claiming that
rock music had subliminal messaging in
it
backwards recordings that would get you
to try to like worship Satan
and they would [__] worse I do yeah
they would play that [__] backwards it
was creepy as [__] it is creepy sounding
like man maybe that's there but we we
would pass that [__] around her [__]
middle school and [__] listen to that
[__] Walkman Walkman and [__] and um
on headphones it would scare the piss
out of you well it is true it's
imperative it's inherently creepy
sounding creepy sound like people
talking backwards it's just inherently
creepy I'm sorry it just is
um so it doesn't even matter what
they're saying or what you can imagine
they're saying it's just creepy they're
focusing in on [__] Stairway to
Heaven and [__] and Led Zeppelin and
yeah and all kinds of and it's like I
used to love that because it's like oh
listen it's saying this and that and the
other I'm like no I don't hear it sorry
well the Beatles song Revolution number
nine I think did have some backwards
recording in it yeah because they were
[__] around they were [__] around
with people which is what I would do too
yeah well a lot of bands actually did
start to do that yeah yeah like after
there was like such a big like oh we're
gonna we're gonna do it then would
[__] say something record it and play
it backwards and then record that end of
the [__] song you can hear them
talking backwards right then you had to
put the stylist on your own phonograph
record turn it backwards so you can
listen to it oh this is those
[__] are saying passenger
you hear him you hear him talk about the
[__] devil yeah yeah
oh my God it's true yeah it's true but
yeah they only did it like because they
were yeah because you were [__] right
because they were talking about it so
it's like hey that's a good idea he had
to grow up in that era to understand
mr88 said nothing brought more kids to
Satan than the 80s than the dumbass
Christians bitching about it yeah kids
would have not have cared if the adults
had just shut up yeah yeah exactly yeah
exactly I I kind of they just they just
made it more of a thing yeah well and
the metal bands back then the horror
movie makers they were like [__] yeah
yeah let's get on let's talk about it
more yeah yeah keep keep on whining yeah
it's like it's our record sales are just
going up and I'm making whole [__]
bands based on it sure but what's funny
is that they would pick on Iron Maiden
and if you actually listen because the
album covers but if you listen to Iron
maiden's music and the songs and the
intent behind them it's classical
English literature yeah Christian
background Christian stuff sure that's
what it is I will never understand
anything called a Christian band
probably basically I will never
understand why people are so bothered by
dark imagery yeah dark imagery [__]
them up I I guess because and I still
know people nowadays that are oh that's
too scary or that's too I'm just like
are you a baby whatever you know what I
mean it's like I don't I don't
understand like why people are so upset
by it I don't get it I can't hang with
people like that it's just oh that's too
scary for me I'm just like okay bye I
don't like it Gen X Jason said I watched
dragged across concrete based on your
review and loved it good move yeah yeah
it was a really good movie I liked it a
lot I worked on it yeah yeah referring
Brian Hackett uh worked on it but um but
yeah that's kind of why uh I had been
wanting to see it for a long time I
don't know why I put it off for so long
but yeah Alice in Wonderland said hell
the Judy Bloom books were poo pooed when
I was a kid yeah I remember them like
[__] freaking out about oh what was
that one
um what was it called I think it was
called dini I think that was the most
controversial one all of the Judy Bloom
books were controversial simply because
she wrote about [__] like it really was
like she wrote about a girl getting her
period or a girl losing her virginity or
some [__] like that and she wrote about
like realistically I think dini might
have had like abortion in it so maybe
that was why but it's just like she read
about [__] realistically and um you know
we can't have that so her books were
always getting [__] banned or people
bitched about or something well they
were more dear well yeah they were more
gear tour teenage girls because it was
kind of more
um what kind of age Coming of Age type
stuff but like I said everybody all the
girls of my generation are probably like
younger all of us read those because
they were um like I said some of the
young some of the um ones that she wrote
like were kind of just silly but they
were all like good and they were all
well written but she did write a bunch
that were relatable because and they
were like really realistic and they kind
of like talked about
issues that teenage girls would face and
it's like so they were very relatable to
a lot of people but yeah they were just
constantly being put on like bands lists
and [__] like that because
you know they I didn't find them
particularly controversial but then I'm
not like an old [__] bitty am I
I'm not an old bitty back in the 80s who
thinks everything who thinks you can't
talk about things yeah you know what I
mean it's like I don't really get it
yeah uh yeah Sarah said just as they
thought rock and roll incited violence
and violent video games yeah and I kind
of feel like they maybe I don't think
they [__] about that as much anymore
but they still kind of give video games
like
a little bit of [__] every time
something bad happens but
yeah nice try with that that well and
the thing about it nowadays is that if
violent video games cause people to be
violent like everybody be killing
everybody nowadays because everybody
plays those everybody
so it's just kind of like there's just
no way that that would cause anything
because it's so widespread condescending
well everybody wants the easy solution
yeah oh well we can solve x Problem by
just eliminating this one thing that's
never that's just not how [__] works
well it's also the they're also
basically saying that people are too
stupid to know the difference between
know the difference between fantasy and
reality
right yeah
and to a large extent most adults and
even most children yeah do you know the
difference unless they have some kind of
psychological issue but that's another
thing that's another thing that needs to
be addressed that doesn't have anything
to do with the video game like I said
you know [__] serial killers they
could go out and kill people after
watching the [__] Sound of Music you
know what I mean nobody would blame The
Sound of Music would they but if it was
a horror movie then they'll blame that
but you know
yeah post that Geraldo found satanic
Panic evidence in Al Capone's secret
vault
pretty it said Geraldo is the worst not
specific to the satanic Panic just the
worst period yeah that guy that guy is
like a Giants [__] douche they were
all giant [__] douche yeah everyone
on TV all those like I said they were
all grifters all they wanted was views
eyeballs yeah yeah you know because they
wanted that sweet ad Revenue well it's
just like nowadays and it all built up
to Morton Downey Jr oh my God yeah or
remember Morton Downey yeah he's dead
he's dead now and his son more down in
June actually he's a lot better but uh
Morton Downey his show was the [__]
worst of the worst it was hilarious
though because he knew he was the worst
well it's it's just kind of like it gets
to a point where you know you start out
kind of normal and nice like Donahue or
something like that where it's like yeah
we're actually talking about yeah it's a
little bit salacious but we're actually
talking about issues and [__] without
being too crazy Donahue ended up going
crazy though but that well yeah but
that's what I mean like as the 80s went
on it's like you had to be more and more
and more out there to get people to
watch because it was so much other
competition weeks and weeks and weeks of
paternity test shows they went that road
for a long time remember that yeah
you're not you're not the father
[Laughter]
and to be honest I think 90 of the
people on those shows were actors
probably
well we know one that went on one of
those shows and he was an actor yeah
yeah I think that was pretty common
especially as as the show topic started
getting weirder and weirder yeah like
I'm I'm marrying my sister what the [__]
who knows about it right it's just like
when they just got stupider and stupider
um you know what I mean uh like what was
that one like Dan Bell put it in one of
his um one of his videos like because he
loves all those old like talk shows and
stuff and he'll like put them in another
dead Mall videos
um one of them was like those those two
ugly that quote unquote mother and
daughter who would like go [__] dudes
and like get money from them and it's
like it's like all we have to do is
Shake our titties and they'll buy us a
car and like and they were like
completely disgusting like they were
like [__] crack [__]
and I'm just like you know that's not
real I mean it might be real I don't
know I think it was real they were just
they were just a real [__] skanky
white trash
mother-daughter team that were running
through guys and they were just running
through guys in the Backwoods somewhere
you know
I'm getting drunk at the hotel yeah they
give them alcohol behind the scenes like
in the green room they do that for one
thing yeah and they also stir up
dissension between the guests especially
if it's one way to try to get them all
to fight yeah like hey this person said
this about you and [__] so they do that
they instigate
[__] behind the scenes and they get them
to exaggerate like you they get YouTube
to say like the most outrageous [__]
imaginable because like I said that's
what people want to see they want to see
people smacking each other and like just
saying like [__] random [__] and like
I said as the 80s and 90s went on it you
had to to get attention you had to be
like more and more outrageous so it just
obviously went that way what's funny is
that all the old systems we grew up with
that they used to use is to just control
our opinions because they would Channel
you through 13 channels basically and uh
maybe some cable channels
they're all falling apart now
yeah it's all going obsolete which is
great no centralized control
you guys don't understand for you young
people how hard it was
before the internet to get information
you were only dependent on [__] radio
and television and everything you know
in in a in a in a library was out of
date
you just kind of had to trust what
authorities told you
you know what what you heard on
television what you heard on the news
now with [__] social media
cell phones and cell phone cameras
you can find out the truth
they can't they can't just spin it all
into a narrative to get you to [__]
give more power to the oligarchs
basically they can't do that anymore
that's why they're so scared
so they should be they're [__]
criminals
but
like I said this is like the 1600s with
the event with the Advent of the [__]
printing press
a lot of powerful Rich families are very
afraid
because they just can't spoon feed
[__] to you anymore well
everything's just all over the place
yeah which like I said that comes with
its own unique set of problems but
honestly
um I like it better I would not go much
better because you can't trust them with
the bullhorn
you know it's just kind of like
everybody is yeah you cannot trust them
with the bullhorn they will abuse it
they have always abused it
honestly like even maybe I don't even
know if this is like statistically true
or not but it does like everybody's
saying it's like oh you know people are
more
um
polarized than they were before and [__]
like that which I'm not sure that's the
case because people have been polarized
a long time but I will say that nowadays
yeah it's much easier to live in your
own little bubble that's for sure
um than it was
in Prior eras but like I said I'm not
entirely sure that's a bad thing I don't
really know no it's easier to find out
the truth well and it's easier to access
other people's viewpoints and opinions
and [__] like that much easier than it
used to be so I think that's um you know
I think that's a positive much easier to
do a research and back and background
research on some so-called Authority
who's trying to [__] his way into a
bunch of money you know what I mean you
can defrock frauds a lot easier
you can search backgrounds of certain
people
you know uh
you can
select who it is you want to hear the
news from you know and what their take
of the news is and it paints
everything's an opinion piece now
everything
but that's good you want a variety of
opinions you didn't get that before you
were just yeah around through the
official [__] opinion
because that made you easier to control
and you know the Americas [__]
economy was entirely based upon Warfare
basically with the military industrial
complex so they would just say these are
the bad people they're against democracy
let's kill them let's kill their
children bomb their [__] cities you
find out later on it had nothing to do
with that it was just about making money
and keeping old men on Pleasure islands
with young girls really that's well like
I said it's much easier nowadays like I
said you know with the Advent of the
internet and [__] like that you're much
less likely to think of someone from
like another country for example as like
the other yeah like hey I play online
games with somebody from there they're
you know they're I know some people from
there they're cool you know what I mean
so it's just kind of like I don't know
it's opened the world up a lot yeah well
it's another thing is there's still a
lot of Americans that are way behind
they think the outside world is just a
bunch of uncivilized Savages
oh my God it's hilarious yeah they think
the foreign countries are like hell you
know I mean well of course they want to
come here where they're coming from is
terrible I grew up in these countries
[__] Central South America those
places are [__] Paradise better food
you know [__] fun yeah some of them
have problems but that we got problems
too there's problems everywhere [__]
the rest of the world's caught up with
us we're not even a military superpower
anymore well I feel like we're not even
and I told and I think I've said this
before but even back in the 1990s when I
went to the UK for the first time
um that cell phones proliferated there
much earlier than they did here I was
there in the 1990s 95 95 96 something
like that
um a lot of people had cell phones back
then and there were cell phone places
like everywhere and that was way before
um they became real widespread in the
U.S so they were like several years
ahead in that regard yeah because I was
surprised I was like holy [__]
everybody's not everybody but a lot of
people had them yeah so these countries
aren't technologically
behind no not at all and in fact some
are ahead yeah some are ahead because
some have never got caught up in the old
systems were caught up like some of
these never had cable TV so they're all
their [__] is internet
you know the whole um the whole tap uh
card thing yeah like the ATM card
they've had that in Europe a long time
ago they were just kind of like
wondering what the [__] is taking you
guys so long that you still got to stick
it in the machine and [__] like that
because they had that like a long time
businesses are involved right there they
want to keep it a certain way so they
make money
um
but yeah I mean uh even places in in on
the African continent some of them are
[__] you know good places to live
what's his name went to Nigeria and he
went through a uh kind of like one of
the upper end neighborhoods and [__]
looked like something in the United
States they got the same [__] yeah [__]
does not really look that different yeah
where are you guys it's like shopping
malls and big stadiums and stuff
everybody's got that [__] I mean not
wakanda but it's a [__] civilized
country just like here in the west you
know so just Americans have a weird view
of the outside world because well it's
so big people they don't they don't go
they don't have to a lot of people don't
go yeah this is it's like 50 countries
all together it's kind of like the EU
bigger you know and I mean yeah and I
don't have to leave I get that because
it's like the United States has so many
natural wonders and so many things like
it would take you a lifetime to see all
the cool [__] that's here so like a lot
of people are just kind of like oh they
never go to other countries yeah but um
because you know there's a lot of [__]
here to see I'm not saying that but it's
just kind of like a lot of people don't
go which is sad yeah because you should
I haven't been a lot of places but you
definitely should go someplace other
than here I've been over a lot of places
here though
been out west been up up north spent
lots of places
um yeah Camp guy said my daughter could
keep up with the smartest adults by the
time she was 12 years old yeah I do kind
of feel like a lot of kids by the time
they're 12 or 13. they're pretty [__]
sharp yeah a motivated person can become
extremely educated just with access to
the internet because it's all there like
I said you can learn anything you want
to know isn't that awesome I just I
would never go back to the 80s
everything was so [__] difficult and
it's just kind of like if you had to
come up with some information you had to
like call the library or you had to like
you had to do some [__] like that now
like in two seconds how do man this [__]
is broken on my car how do I fix that
yeah I think five seconds later oh okay
I can sit around for hours and just
listen to Avi lobe one of the professors
at Universe you know Harvard University
talking about you know extraterrestrials
and [__] you know cosmology you know
you can just listen to him for hours on
these talk shows long form talk shows
they didn't have that in television back
then
you know you couldn't learn anything off
TV it was too stupid
TV was done I mean like I said now you
can learn anything anything
any [__] topic you want you just
[__] look for it and you can find all
kind of [__] it's great yep campy I said
my kids barely know or have seen a pay
telephone yeah you don't really see them
that much anymore do you my grandkid
won't know what a payphone is except as
an antique hunk of metal yep well I kind
of feel like now like kids if they saw
one they'd be like what the [__] is that
yeah because it doesn't look anything
like a phone like they would recognize
it which is really funny I can't even
remember when was the last time I saw a
payphone I saw one the other day like in
a building and I was like what the [__]
is that doing there
when actually when you open up a cell
phone or a tablet
I couldn't have imagined that in the 80s
with the internet and everything I
couldn't that would have been just like
God like power something you could yeah
I couldn't even dream of that or imagine
that
yeah think of if if you kind of just sit
back and think of all the [__] we have
now yeah that we don't that we really
just take for granted because like I
said we were here the whole time so we
saw all of it develop and you're like oh
that's neat oh that's neat but like if
you just kind of forget that all that
happened and you're just like look at
all the [__] we have now you make a list
and then if you went back to the 80s and
like said hey we're gonna have this that
and the other thing that would blow your
[__] mind yeah it would blow your
[__] mind what's funny is you go back
and look through history
human history going back to thousands of
years governments caused no progress if
anything governments cause just nothing
but damage where progress came from it
was all technology
Empires that rise and fall governments
would come and go
the Advent of Technology continued to
climb even when [__] Rome fell
technology moved on
the so-called barbarians had better
Metallurgy and better better technology
than than the Romans did they just
didn't quite apply it the same way they
didn't have a big Empire
um but uh that's what's happening now
things like cell phones internet and
physical everything to do with that
those companies that make that are
actually kind of subservient to those
corporations
you got to watch corporations too
corporations are dangerous you'll have
Wayland Industries before you know it in
[__] time if we don't already we
already do yeah they own our government
I'm pretty sure because if you look at
who you who you vote for they're always
siding pretty much they pretty much side
for
whatever [__] corporate you know the
powerful corporations
they're just their employees
everything is just theater
uh I'm not sure if I'm pronouncing your
screen name correctly but uh dentosama
dentist
says growing up with house phone and
cable feels so different especially when
I'm in the desert uh either from Arizona
yeah it's just it's just weird to think
about it's weird to think that the first
half
of my life
we didn't have any we didn't have any
inkling of the internet
you just I remember when we first got
cable and it was just kind of like you
had the little [__] box that sat on
top of your TV that like slid like to
the channels and it was just kind of
like and I think there was like
72 spots we didn't have that many
channels back then
I think we had 40-something channels and
that freaked us out because when I was a
kid you just had like three well you had
three and then you had PBS and then when
we got
Fox 35 that was like a huge deal because
like oh my God a new channel whoever
heard of such a thing like when I was a
kid so it was like a freaky and then
like you got the cable in the early 80s
and we're like 48 channels holy [__]
what could possibly be on all of those a
bunch of crap as it turned out but there
was a lot of good [__] too but I'm just
saying so now it's just like there's so
much entertainment this is why I was
thinking about this earlier today
I said this is why I'm not a big fan of
people that just you know because you
know there's a lot of YouTube channels
or other channels that like their whole
shtick is just like complaining about
media like movies and TV shows and stuff
like that and I said in a way I don't
really understand that because
dude I'm like in this day and age you
have essentially infinite entertainment
infinite you will never live long enough
to see all of it and if you don't like
this thing why waste your [__] time
bitching about it there's something out
there that you will like I guarantee it
there's just so much so to me it just
seems like a huge waste of time like
pissing and moaning about [__] you don't
like I'm like just go find something you
do like it's got to be there somewhere
like I said you have essentially
infinite entertainment nowadays and a
lot of it is free
so I just I find that I can't complain
about that kind of [__] because that
never would have happened before before
if I wanted to see a movie and I grew up
in Daytona Beach and if it was a big
Blockbuster they'd show it but other
than that if it was like an indie movie
or foreign or something you couldn't see
it so it's like I'd have to wait until
it came out on DVD and then I have to
order it so and it was expensive so it
was just like a big deal like to see
something so it you know it was kind of
this big thing it's like man I want to
see this Lucio Fouche movie and it's
like you know what I mean you couldn't
get it
so I've already had to wait till I went
to New York and went to like the video
store up there and bought it or some
[__] like that so you had to save up so
the fact that now that you can see 99 of
everything that's ever been produced
like with the click of a button for a
couple of bucks is
astounding I mean that's astounding
availability is astounding today it's
astounding just the closest the clothes
you can get at a touch of it right but
just on you know just on your phone
you can get phone you can get any kind
of clothing you want for cheap delivered
to your door
and we talked about this before growing
up kind of in the gothic subculture it
was a [__] finding clothes yeah yeah
you either had to go to like the thrift
store and like buy something and then
make it you know and then sew it and
like make it your own like alter it or
you had to order [__] from Europe or
from New York or something like that and
it was super expensive like you can just
I've told the show I think I've told
this on the show several times already
back in the uh late 90s when I was with
my first wife
I was at her place of business
and uh because it was relaxed I could go
there and go hang out
and uh
I went there because she had a computer
with internet
not everybody had internet in those days
and we ordered some golf clothes over
the internet from Hot Topic
you could get [__] on the online store
and they didn't have it at the local
store if you're you know what I mean in
your shop
so we bought several hundred dollars
worth of [__] maybe 300 out of 400 you
didn't get that much back then it was
expensive
and it was so [__] weird to me that I
and I got that with my ATM card
and a few days later it showed up at the
house I was just astounded I thought I
thought I was in [__] total or
[__] that's hilarious or [__] the
running man but it seemed like that at
the time yeah I was like oh my God I
can't I got and I got this and this and
that thought I got this over the over a
computer
and I thought of the [__] Hot Topic
store in the mall and I was like what's
that mall doing there what what do I
need that mall for
well that's how it went that's what
happened we don't need that
[__] well like I said decades now I said
now it's like 97. you got a phone and
it's just kind of like I'm gonna do an
instacart hey somebody go buy my
groceries for me yeah two hours later
all your groceries turn up on you and
for a few months later then a few months
later for 100 bucks you can buy this
little console
TV remember that it had a [__] uh we
didn't have it but I remember it had a
wireless keyboard you could you could go
you could go into the internet and do a
lot most of the [__] that you could do
during those days
yeah you could do it over your
television this is before cell phones
were really feasible
and uh the internet was not a big place
that was 90s internet yeah which was a
spooky place kind of like the wild west
and you weren't sure
you weren't sure if what you were seeing
was true and all the websites were ugly
yeah
and all the time with like little lines
under it and [__] like that
oh yeah like rotating like spinning
little gifts some kind of nostalgic
about it though
well why do you think there's a whole
you know there's a whole sub-genre of
horror called analog horror yeah and a
lot of it has to do with a lot of it's
like videotape and [__] like that from
the 80s but a lot of it too is like
early internet [__] right like so people
will recreate like old [__] websites
from the 90s and [__] like that like in
a horror context it's pretty cool
actually I kind of feel like it's sort
of on the decline now because it kind of
had a big splash like message boards
yeah I used to go on this message board
it was called uh Colette kalishnikov
dot something or other been a long time
it's been on it and you could just talk
about AKs because I had AKs at the time
I had AK-74 and I built it it was a
retinal cool gear rebuilt it so it
looked just like one of the military
ones with the [__] muzzle break on it
and uh correct furniture and got and one
of the [__] top users on there was to
do with a screen named Tonto and he was
in the Collision Factory in Russia it
blew our [__] minds he was like a
celebrity on there
he could answer anything about all those
these all these [__] rifles and he
would upload photographs or [__] that
they were making in the shop at the
Kalashnikov [__] Factory this is
after the Soviet Union had collapsed but
the Kalashnikov company was still there
still working they were making stuff
handmade prototypes I saw that bison
submachine gun the handmade prototypes
that he and his friend were making
before that [__] came out only gun guys
know what I'm talking about
it's kind of an AKA nine millimeter
Makarov [__] helical feed submachine
gun
he was on that program so it was just it
was a total mind [__] in the 90s
to be talking to guys in other [__]
countries building exotic ex-soviet
weaponry and you know the guy
that was like from another [__] plan
I'm friends with the dude that built
this you know [__] because you could
talk to him back in there wasn't a lot
of guys a few hundred guys on the board
that was it well I think people take it
for granted nowadays that you can just
like send a message to a celebrity yeah
and they'll see it and they'll see it
that didn't exist which it didn't really
because I mean back in the old days it
was kind of like that was like a
different tier of person yeah they were
almost like elevated above yeah the rest
of us [__] so it's like yeah
you could send him a letter or something
like that but it's not like they would
answer you yeah like you couldn't
interact with them YouTubers like me and
Jim we would have been kind of like back
in the days we were kind of like the
television the local television
people of that era or you know what how
am I trying to word YouTubers are kind
of like television people of today right
that's the way television used to be
seen television was not taken seriously
television was like third rate
First Rate was Hollywood movies yeah
that was first rate
but
TV was like third rate
so we kind of replaced that there's more
of us there's more democratized
it was funny because we used to
fantasize about getting your own [__]
local local access Channel yeah yeah we
can have our own TV channel through
cable it only cost us a couple hundred a
month we should do it that kind of [__]
not realizing it takes thousands and
thousands of dollars a month to keep
that [__] running and you won't you
won't get you wouldn't get anything from
it you wouldn't get anything out of it
you'd lose all your buddies but we
didn't do it because the only reason
that like TV shows made money was
because yeah they had commercials yeah
they paid for the [__] yeah
um Zach says I still say a show about
famous internet scams or computer
viruses would be really interesting it
probably would actually I should
probably do that American Military 100
said Jenny and Tom have you guys
considered doing an episode on spooky or
mysterious internet sites or creepy
videos we did do one yeah um we should
do it I don't remember what all we did
on it but there's so much stuff out
there that we could probably do another
volume yeah so maybe I should there's a
guy who's really good at this his name
of his channel is wag yeah he's like a
long-haired kind of Korean American guy
I think he's Korean he does a lot of
good shows on that and does follow-ups
try to solve old internet mysteries from
the 90s that kind of [__]
he's real good at that one that is like
really fascinating yeah I love all that
kind of stuff the internet was much more
mysterious in the 90s yeah no one was
quite sure yeah what direction it was
going you weren't and you weren't sure
what you were seeing was real or if it
was faked
Zach says oh I love Wang he's so hot
yeah it went good yeah he's a good
looking dude I will say yeah looks like
[__] uh uh
like some kind of Mongol Warrior
he does a bit Yeah from like you know
I'm trying to think is Khan he's a
long-haired kind of Korean American guy
he's with the [__] mustache and beard
like mine kind of young guy you're Ming
the man
quite quite entertaining good good show
I think it ends with an exclamation
point I don't remember yeah that's what
that's what w-a-n-g he says w h w h a n
g with an exclamation yeah a real good
Channel I'm giving a shout out
got a lot of good stuff and he'll do
he'll he'll his show is good because he
can do like a 20 minute show too they're
not live right she just posts a lot of
them
like the he had a whole series of shows
trying to track down a [__] song
yeah I remember you telling me about
that it's a really good dark wave song
and they don't know who did it see I
love [__] like that yes I love [__] like
that somebody just had a recording of it
off the off of a German radio station
that played darkwave music and early
Indie type music
and they recorded it and it was on a
cassette tape
and that song got passed around over and
over again and nobody knows who made
that song but it is a great song yeah
it's kind of like like a Joy Division
Song kind of yeah
I remember you like showing me that and
I think it's in German yeah or Russian I
don't remember
it might be English but the accent
sounds German or the accent sounds
Russian they don't know who who did it
Zack says by the way Jenny I think you'd
like the internet investigator she's uh
this goth chick with the deepest [__]
Voice who does videos on internet urban
legends and disturbing stuff it's so
cool yeah that sounds like right at my
alley yeah I'm really into that kind of
[__] but like I said we did do a show on
creepy internet videos
and I think we covered a lot of the kind
of the classics uh from back in the old
days but there's so much
material there that we could absolutely
do a volume two of that because like I
love that kind of [__] yeah creepy
internet [__] I'm really into
um you guys probably have heard of
Mexico right like he does
um a lot of analog horror and he does
like ARG type stuff and he does like
really long he doesn't post a lot but he
does really long breakdowns of like ARG
series and stuff like that
um and he's got a great voice like it's
very uh atmospheric so I really like to
listen to those he usually puts up one
that's like an hour or an hour and a
half long something like that but um
yeah so I I love all that kind of
like anything to do with like ARG or
like old mysterious like internet [__]
like from the early days of the internet
is like really cool there's something
really creepy about it
yeah somebody just brought up next bow
yeah I really like nexbo I really like
nexbo
um but yeah all right so do you you seem
like you want to wrap it up you want to
wrap it up yeah we wrap it up because
it's we're at two hours late yeah it is
kind of getting late yeah
I'm getting hungry too I don't know
about you I'm kind of hungry too I guess
maybe we should get something to eat
we're always hungry what are we talking
about we didn't eat much today we eat
very little we didn't and I just had
that no I went no I would never okay
well you think as soon as you like the
house I don't know no no I don't really
I don't know because you went out to
test drive your bike today so you were
gone for a couple hours well no you were
test you were test riding it yeah yeah
how long how long were you gone
a couple of hour two hours something
like that yeah like so you were just out
tooling around doing whatever it is that
yeah stop got some drink of Starbucks
yeah I figured you probably stopped at
Starbucks because you yeah I sent you
the message you messaged me from there
yeah so I figured that's where it was
good I had a place to throw out bearing
in the [__] clutch yeah on the xb12
but no I did I did not eat a single
thing like while you were I didn't eat
anything I had two cups of coffee this
morning
and then you gave me some of the
vegetable curry yeah Jen's getting in
real good that you made Ken's getting in
real good shape she looked her legs look
totally different she's I told you I
just got into that [__] corset that I
haven't been able to get into for like a
year or two yeah yeah any people who are
seeing any of our other video projects
are adult video stuff Jen looks good in
those man she looks very different now
Jen's starting to become
I've lost a lot of weight since those
yeah and built up a lot and I'm recomp
well I have three compositions yeah I
went in the gym this morning yeah doing
my he puts here's okay so we have a
bench thing against the wall
and he puts the
the Olympic the Olympic Bar yeah against
my stomach right there you gotta push
your butt up yeah like that it's a glute
thrust like a yeah a glue thrust gives
you a big boost so I was doing a bunch
of those today
did a bunch of leg work today yeah legs
legs and butt and
and yeah in the lower back uh and top of
the back of the butt
um that's deadlift guys to give to give
yeah I was doing this like deadlift I
was doing that similar to deadlift yeah
yeah I was doing those as well yeah so
got in there and wore my ass out yeah oh
you just you also did weighted sit-ups
oh that's right I forgot about that yeah
weighted synapse I think I did 75 of
those yeah
she's probably dropped 25 pounds in
about a month
or fat yeah last time I weighed well
probably probably lost more you're
probably more like lost 30 pounds of fat
and gained back five pounds of muscle on
top
because for however much I weigh which
I'm not saying but um but I look a lot I
think I look a lot thinner than my
weight would suggest yeah I will say
that you look like you weigh about 130.
but I weigh like more than that much
more yeah not much more I was surprised
like I said when I looked yesterday like
before we did streamate and I had my
little dress on that you bought me and
my from the side like my rib cage looked
like really really thin and I was like
holy [__] look at that yeah because I
don't usually look that thin up there
yeah
because for some reason I tend to carry
a lot of my weight in my abdomen area
unfortunately
I'm not like one of those lucky ladies
that it's like when they gain weight
it's like oh it all goes into their ass
and their tits it's like nope mine goes
right to my midsection for you for you
ladies that are you know over the age of
35 trying to get in shape using cardio
good luck it'll never happen
it's got to be weight training and you
got to have your hormones looked at you
as much as I hate to yeah
do it yeah
yeah wait train
well I I will say like it's like slow
torture but um at least it's over
quickly yeah it's more concentrated I
will say that yeah I don't enjoy it I
know more like a sledgehammer yeah
and it's just and I'm in there going ah
kill me you know what I mean yeah and if
you don't have any hormones in your body
after 35 and most women don't you you
your cells just don't really respond to
the training you can train train you get
tired you go to sleep nothing happens
you wake up you're exactly the way you
were yeah
and just because your sales just don't
work you got to be all gear but honestly
the between the weight
lifting and the calorie restriction
which I have been doing that too yeah
and the stuff yeah yeah high protein low
carb yeah I still eat carbs I'm not
saying I don't need carbs but a lot more
protein a lot more protein just I try to
eat just meat vegetables and a tiny tiny
bit of carbs yeah
um but um between those two things and
whatever [__] that you have me on yeah
um
that seems to be like working very
effectively I have I have lost
easily 25 pounds yeah last month in the
last month yeah
and it's and it's weird because like I
look in the mirror and I'm just like
holy [__] like it's a problem like my
legs and [__] like that look completely
different like the wedding photos that
we took yeah because the lady took them
like full body I was like oh my god look
how [__] skinny my legs are yeah I
can't remember the last time my legs
looked that small well they're shapely
too
yeah
oh my God camp guy said aerobicize is
the hottest thing I'd ever seen when I
was a Randy young man yeah leg warmers
and headbands as well yeah so like I
would compete with the girls on the
video to do as many donkey kicks as they
did
I remember that was very big in the 80s
they had those [__] high-waisted yeah
or no it would like the thighs would
come like way up here the leotards and
stuff and it's just kind of like they'd
have the [__] headbands in the big
[__] hair oh my God yeah aerobics
just wishful thinking that that's girl
that's girl exercises am I it might work
if you're a teenager it works when
you're young you're 20s but once you're
old as [__] like me it doesn't work as
well they have a high impact on the
[__]
it's got to have a very high impact on
the body and uh you have to be taking
supplements I'm gonna use [__] You
Gotta Be You gotta be on steroids okay
that's that's the truth you gotta be on
steroids pretty much when you're older
because it's just a synthetic hormones
yeah like I said I don't like he injects
me this stuff I don't know what it is
exactly well I kind of know what it is
but it's deca
100 milligrams shit's working good yeah
yeah I didn't
turned out later in the natural loans
traditionally in the women
old school
Sports Medicine women weren't given that
but you had to look at the age
demographics of the of who was being
trained on this [__] for older later on
I started talking to doctors
and Sports Medicine doctors and they
said oh no you know a woman
post-menopause can take real gear you
just have to get to keep the doses
reasonable you know yeah and that's 19
North testosterone Branch naturally
alone
wouldn't give a Tran but MPP well you
better not take it either we've had
experiences yeah yeah
but yeah you guys know
you're not allowed to take that anymore
also you know also known as Deca you
could take that about 100 milligrams
but you got to be a training it's not
it's not like you just take it and it's
a miracle cure you got to be you got to
be put demands on the body
they didn't [__] highly effective on
her
it was the first thing that actually
like that I saw yeah very quickly that I
saw like a um like a result yeah like my
whole like the whole composition like
started changing yeah the whole shape
started changing yeah it's a lot safer
than test for one testosterone I told
you that I got like and soaked soaked
test up I take a lot of testosterone
yeah he does [__] it I'll take 400
milligrams of that a week and then I'll
put steroids on top of it yeah but uh I
never go above a thousand but I mean
you're fine you're not acting crazy or
not yeah yeah not like not like when you
were on Trend when you were asking
acting like a super villain yeah but um
Trent does that to everybody yeah pretty
much most people yeah they have that
same and again I wouldn't I wouldn't
advise taking it unless you're single
yeah
my [__] I usually keep it under 1000
milligrams per week of anything mixtures
of [__] tests and steroids
to give you guys a kind of perspective
1 000 milligrams would be very very
entry level bodybuilders [__]
Pro bodybuilders like between four and
six thousand milligrams a week that's a
[__] [__] ton I don't understand how
to do it
and that's a lot of money too
yeah I don't know a lot of money [__]
man
I mean our [__] is like expensive it's
not that expensive but it's kind of yeah
that would be 300 uh probably three four
four hundred five hundred dollars a
month
yeah that's a lot
yeah about 500 probably
I did get another I told you five six I
did get another comment on one of our
YouTube video I can't remember what
video it was but about um asking what
had happened to my voice over the years
yeah
I was kind of going to answer and be an
[__] but I was just kind of like oh
I'm turning into a dude didn't you know
yeah but um no
okay it's just because of that it's just
because and I was showing Jan it's not
even
um
it's not the stuff that I'm on now
that's doing it no it was already like
it was the stuff that was that I took
before yeah it made my vocal cords
thicker it was Maestro Winstrol did it
yeah because you were that was more
associated with uh
um
aerobic work is what you were doing at
the time that's what endurance Runners
take which can give you kind of more of
a Slender type build
but you weren't putting enough aerobic
stress on yourself to really get the
rewards out of what I was giving you
although it did keep weight off you it
did
um but it did it deep in my voice if you
were actually running it deep in my
voice and it kind of bothered me at the
time but then I was just kind of like I
mean it didn't bother me until people
started pointing it out yeah and then I
was then I started getting
self-conscious about it but now I don't
really give a crap about it anymore yeah
it is reversible it takes time but it's
reversible it won't reverse under the
effects of what you're on now though
that's okay it'll stay like that and I'm
just kind of like today I'm just kind of
used to it yeah to make Jenny to give it
to perspective and Jen I showed her some
[__] girls in porn that are on gear
he's trying to make me feel better just
look see this [__] and she's hot as [__]
and then you hear her talk and she's
[__] twice as bad as you her name is
Amy Anderson yeah she says yeah he
showed me her and he's like listen to
her voice yeah she sounds like a duck
she's got a lot of gear she does yeah
you wouldn't know by looking at it well
you're a pro her voice isn't deeper than
mine it's just that I suspect it's real
amazing that her voice is deeper than
mine but she's trying to put on a fake
voice to make it sound like not and it
ends up like I said sounding like a duck
it's super annoying yeah yeah it's super
annoying yeah she's super hot but I'm
like how about you not talk yeah it's
just kind of that right I said it
reminded me of if you guys have seen we
did a review of it she's what they call
it she's the bimbo fish yeah yeah she
looks like a Barbie doll yeah she's like
her lips yeah yeah titties big she's
like the classic perfect body yeah Amy
Anderson is her name
what the [__] but yeah she sounds like a
duck she does but her voice is really
annoying like I said it reminded me of
if you guys have seen the Steve Martin
movie The Man with Two Brains from the
80s there's like a um like a prostitute
in that who's like super super hot and
she's blonde and like the nice tits and
everything and she opens like the the
fur coat and she's like she's naked and
all this other stuff and then she talks
and she's like what's the matter with my
voice it's like it kind of reminded me
of that I was like it wasn't that bad
but almost
yeah
yeah in the case and Amy
she was probably on a lot of gear to get
she's got a phenomenal figure okay
um
she's if you're gonna look at like the
bimbo fetish she's got it that's what
that's what it's supposed to look like
yeah that's her whole thing and who
knows what she started off looking like
probably nothing or sounding like well
we don't know she just sounded like a
chick yeah but she didn't look like that
no way she didn't start off looking like
that
so she took a lot of gear to get like
and she's probably on a pretty good
amount to maintain that physique
which means that the voice didn't kind
of go back to normal because it's
constantly being maintained it's
definitely not normal yeah well I'm used
to it though yeah a lot of them are like
that I kind of wondered though like when
you showed it to me and I was watching
it in like the British dude that was you
know that was humping her in the in the
video I was just kind of like is that
dude being like man I wish this [__]
would shut up
[Laughter]
she's not that bad no I don't
know I was wondering but then there's a
[__] open class Pro bodybuilder named
named Chelsea and I like Chelsea I've
talked to Chelsea live on on her [__]
streams and [__]
and Chelsea's
she's outside the female rage her voice
she's still attractive
yeah I think so as well she's just
nothing but solid muscle she looks like
the Hulk with with it yeah imagine the
Hulk with implants
yeah she's a she's a she's a big woman
yeah she's a she's stronger than me much
stronger than me yeah she could probably
she could probably like pound you and
she's probably only about five two
uh so my size yeah it probably weighs
200 something pounds it's all muscle
she's like she's a monster yeah she has
like no body fat she looks like an
anatomy poster
and
it's kind of funny because she puts
makeup on and she yeah it's cute and
pretty and [__] and she talks and she's
she's got a real deep voice
but she I think she's sexy other people
you know other people other guys they're
gonna get [__] cucked out behind
they're gonna get sensitive you know
what I mean because yeah she could
[__] tear you apart
[Laughter]
flirt with it well I like that like I
said that's one thing that I like about
you Tom and I kind of have this as well
you have like a wide range
of stuff that you find attractive yeah
which I do as well yeah well there's a
lot of different brands sure you know
what I mean if the woman has perfected
her brand I'm about it yeah okay yeah
that's it that works too yeah
yeah well I'm kind of that way about
this like I said I'm not really dude
yeah I'm not real like dude she thinks
cute and I'm looking and I'm like I'm
kind of disgusted like too skinny you
know what I mean nerdy looking but
that's what she was
he had perfected that brand sure yeah
though I do look kind of like skinny
nerdy yeah I also like little tiny nerdy
chicks yeah but that's not like the only
type that I like it depends on the
person like I said it depends on the
individual if they have a thing and they
have an aesthetic and they have a whole
thing going on that I'm gonna be I'm
like all right I see what you're doing
there I like that but yeah like I said I
Tom is very um
uh wide range he's very he's very
special Broadband he's very Broadband in
uh what he finds attractive because
that's like well sometimes like he'll
like show me some porn or something like
that and be like that yeah that chick's
hot or is it like the only thing that
you seem to not like is skinny yeah I
don't like skinny too much he doesn't
like skinny flat girls no but other than
that it's pretty wide open this chick
right there
this chick right there she's a gear
Queen too all right and uh her voice is
like twice as rough as Jen's and and I
think she's gorgeous
yeah I mean you know Tom's gotten a lot
into the fitness chicks yeah
because since he started doing it yeah
and that she's not natural she lives
here in Florida
that's baccar nabiva yeah
yeah I'll show you Chelsea
but yeah like I said I kind of like that
about it
because you're just kind of like Ah
that's sexy too that's that works
that works
like I said the really the only thing
you don't seem to be into
super skinny girl no skin if you're
skinny and flat you're out of the runner
but other than that it seems pretty
it seems everything is on the menu other
than that
that's Chelsea yeah
yeah she's got that's her Instagram
right yeah yeah
and hey who you know I think if a woman
can look like that look like that if you
want to that's what she wanted well like
I said it's just for us you know we're
into
fetish and body modifications in Kink
and that's her body mod yeah she wanted
to look like that I'm like all right
fine that's it you got the brand that's
it she said it looks awesome well see
that's what I mean that's why I'm not
like real uptight about [__] because I'm
like look if whatever look you want to
have yeah just do that do that right
just do that
I don't think people should give you
[__] about it no people say however you
want to look well she looks like a man
no man with that amount of muscle looks
like that if you put her next to an
equivalent male like a dude who's just
extremely jacked she looks like a woman
next to that guy
yeah she's like yeah I'm drinking the
Thousand sponsors I think
yeah I don't like them like I said just
you know get off people's Gates yeah
like I said I don't really I don't like
I said it doesn't bother me but I just
think it's funny that like people would
comment on my voice getting deeper I
don't know I just think that's funny
because I'm like why would you like
spend like waste your time
I don't know I don't know why people
would waste their time like
[__] on people
that they don't know and that's Chelsea
I think she's pretty you know who she
reminds me of her face she looks like um
Lori Holden the actress that plays uh
that played Andrea yeah exactly like her
face kind of looks like that yeah kind
of reminds me like the same she has the
same shape face and the mouth and stuff
her voice sounds like mine though it
does a bit oh yeah her voice her her
voice is yeah because he showed me like
Instagram yeah and stuff yeah but you
know still
I think she's cute
sorry yeah well you're not gonna
apologize she looks like it just sounds
like a man she's looking like a man well
yeah when you stand next to her she
looks like a man and you look like a
woman
she looks like a worm
but when I stand next to you dude you
look like a woman too if I were to have
sex with you it wouldn't even be gay it
wouldn't even be gay that's what yeah
wouldn't he be gay because we do a blood
test analysis and a differential between
my testy level and your test level
that's the same difference just like
twice the difference between a man and a
woman so again you're a woman next to me
dude
your woman next to her you know so
well like I said I kind of feel like
it's just all dudes that are intimidated
yeah that's all it is yeah which so we
can just dismiss that because it's like
what are they cry what are they crying
about
you're obviously just intimidated
because you can kick your ass well it's
like me and Jen went to uh we went to
the to the
Chinese buffet and afterwards we went to
get a cup of coffee at Joe mugs
and I hear these two chicks behind me
and I turn around and look see who was
talking and it was a it was a little fat
boy with his girlfriend and he sounded
just like a woman to me remember that
yeah I was astounded like I said I
didn't get so much this I got well they
were loud I think that's what because
they were talking very loudly yeah which
annoyed me because I'm just like shut up
no one cares and his voice was yeah High
and high pitched and Twitter you know so
you know yeah compared to him you sound
like a man
yeah yeah I'm all right I'm I'm pretty
Zen with that now I think that dude
sounded like [__] to me it just sounded
like a [__] I didn't actually realize
like how different my voice sounded
until I did go back all right yeah well
a friend of ours I'm not gonna say their
name but um she said oh I was watching
one of your old videos the other day and
your voice was like so much higher
um and I was like really because like I
didn't really notice because it was a
slow progression so I went back and
listened to it I was like holy [__] I
did sound like a lot different yeah but
yeah absolutely it did happen slowly but
she's jealous though she's fat
well yeah I do kind of like she's fat
and and your age so she wants you to
stop
yeah like not see what I'm getting yeah
well I'm to the age now look I'm gonna
be 51 on Tuesday yeah and I was like the
coolest thing about being 51 years old
is that you no longer give a single [__]
what anybody thinks about you anymore
it's awesome I love it that's like the
best thing about getting older like a
lot of things suck about getting older
but that's the absolute best thing and I
think it almost might be worth all the
other [__]
is because you know when you're younger
you're just like really concerned about
oh my God this these people are going to
be mad about this or it's like you know
and it's like really anxiety inducing
and I was kind of like that too but like
once you get to my age you're like who
[__] cares man what the [__] do they
know nothing so it's like so I don't
worry about it it's awesome he can't do
HRT because his doctor said his prostate
wouldn't it
but my experience I wouldn't listen to a
thing of a goddamn thing a [__]
doctor says they don't know what the
[__] they're talking about
Duggan I went on test and all problems
like that I had went away
so I mean you really did and like I said
we're not doctors I'm not telling
everybody to like do the [__] but I mean
in your case yeah you've really I mean
you are completely different I had
[__] type 2 diabetes all that went
away
you know yeah you got that from me yeah
they just don't want you on that because
it's not patented medicine
the patents ran out I mean your mood is
a lot better just like everything you
Pat the pads ran on ran out on those way
back in the [__] 60s and [__] no and
um so they can't really make any profit
off of them it's it's better for them to
have you on statins and [__] all
kinds of [__]
[__] treatments they make they make
money on treatments not cures
a lot of the problems with aging is
hormone starvation
the trick is with women
women are hard to [__] with we're
complicated because what are you gonna
do return her to the [__]
return her to the [__] uh the [__]
what do you call it hormonal profile of
a [__] 14 year old girl or three
times that of a 14 year old girl
they're [__] crazy you you don't want
that it's better it's better just let
them go post menopausal and just do
things that like likes
like steroids which is testosterone with
the [__]
masculinizing [__] features
diminished
you know so they take more of that than
they can't test
there's this whole [__] underground
studies and doctors do all this [__]
they know all this stuff
it was doctors that made all them
steroids they took them too
but when you say steroids they think
it's some open-class bodybuilder and
that's not what they're for
you know just a speed healing
but they can also help in anti-aging
I mean [__] Jack LaLanne was on that
[__] he think he died at 97. he was
doing breaking records well well into
his 50s and his 60s
you look good
all the way into his 90s
they got dudes that are in their [__]
70s they're just [__] ripped
it can be done yeah no they didn't look
like that in their 20s or their teens
had they gotten ripped like that and
tried to maintain that for [__] 60 70
years now I'd [__] them up you do it in
the latter half of your life
it's probably better to do it like that
yeah there's only so much gas and
there's almost some there's only so much
fuel in your tank you're gonna burn up
your [__] fuel
and if you start burning it up young
[__] then there's complications later
on
it's [__] you that's [__] you do after
35 and you keep a Sade
yeah just like anything else it's just
kind of like because if you start out
doing stuff young and then you have to
then it'll [__] you up but yeah if you
start out later it's it seems fine
Arnold was chewing down [__] ahead of
our pills and [__] doing [__]
tests but you know they're pretty high
levels back when he was in high school
my understanding
yeah I wouldn't advise that by the time
he was 19 your [__] was huge
yeah
and you look at his physique and there's
no way that was natural
no way well like you said is like the
younger you start like the more you have
to take to maintain it and all this
other kind of [__] and if you stop
taking it like you start getting fat and
it's just kind of like yeah you know it
and it can cause like other health
problems as well well you when you're
coming off of it you can
their testosterone suppressive
so your nets stop making testosterone
it's about going on birth control yeah
the exact same thing you do to a woman
when you put her on progesterone [__]
make her [__] shuts down you shut you
put test put a guy on test and his
normal production will shut down so when
you come off of it you got to get your
nuts Wicked you got to wake them back up
so you wake up your neck yeah so you can
start producing
now if you're young and you come off of
it you produce a lot
probably enough to maintain the muscle
that you built over the past couple
years
but when you're my age if I were to wake
my nuts back up there wouldn't be enough
tests there to begin with right so you
know once you beyond 40 you're going to
be on test for life
which I'm happy
to do that yeah the alternative is just
get old and fat and fall [__] apart you
get diabetes yeah
it's better just take the test it's
cheaper and you have to worry about all
the diabetes treatment yeah when you
think about it that way yeah and it is
like much cheaper than all the leaner
and [__]
eating that [__] guys in their 20s
and [__] guy got my wife's ass again
okay
you know
good sexual appetite yeah sure oh my God
Kitty's in there yeah so just take the
test
take testosterone that's way out of that
and don't ever worry about coming off
same thing girls do when they [__]
get tit implants you can have implants
for the rest of your life
was that a bad thing that's not a bad
thing well it's an investment in your
future you're all right
Jeffy Hart says wake up your nuts sounds
like Tom should promote breakfast
cereals
look let's get off here Jim we've been
on this forever all right yeah okay
let's got to make some I am kind of
hungry yeah all right so thank you
everybody for dropping by this evening
this has been a fun show I mean you know
the first part was [__] up but at
least we got through all the stuff and
then wandered off on some of our other
tangents like we usually do so hopefully
you guys can drop by on uh Friday for
our Sidetrack show where we'll talk
about even more [__] or whatever it
is that we usually talk about uh those
are usually fun
so hopefully we'll see you guys then and
we will oh Victor just got here hey I
made it
now I feel kind of bad
yeah because we're gonna go get
something to eat we've been on for two
and a half hours yeah all right so sorry
about that picture all right so we'll
see you guys again on Friday night good
night